had to think that whoever was behind me
was just one of the employees but then
seemingly just to disprove that theory
the guy who moves closer to me and
starts breathing down my neck I was
getting very uncomfortable but then just
as I was about to say something hello
and welcome to all Danes a creepypasta
horror stories cooked to perfection with
a splash of red sauce my name is Susie
and I will be your server in this
episode today's special comes in many
courses as we celebrate the 10th episode
of this series we're gonna be looking
back at some of the best stories from
season 1 this is gonna be a long
compilation of original scary stories so
I'd recommend throwing this on to listen
to in the background during school or
work while you're in the car while
you're surfing the web or if you're
really brave put this video on before
bed and see if you can fall asleep now I
don't usually say this until the end and
I do kind of hate when youtubers bring
this up before you've watched the actual
video but since this is such a long one
I think now is a good time to remind you
to make sure you've subscribed to the
channel and turn death bell
notifications on so you don't miss out
on new Horrors every week oh and one
more thing I've hidden a surprise
somewhere in this video so those of you
who listened through the entire thing
will get to see it so with all the
formalities out of the way let's dig
right in number one this strange man is
in all of my dreams
[Music]
I'm sitting in an airport right now my
flight is delayed so I'm going to do my
best to write this story before it's
time to board the flight
have you ever dreamed of a character who
seems to only exist in your dreams most
of the characters in my dreams are
people that I know in real life
occasionally I'll dream of a character
from a TV show or a celebrity crush but
the point is they're all people that I
can picture in my head sure there may be
one that I made up from time to time but
if that does happen they're usually only
going to appear in one dream except for
this one guy the last few years this guy
has been in almost every one of my
dreams at least the ones that I can
remember as far as I know he's never had
a name he's bald
probably in his 60s or something um I
suck at guessing people's ages he has a
thin mustache and wrinkles around his
eyes yellow teeth not real straight I
wouldn't call him overweight but he's
definitely not in shape the strange
thing is this is the first time I've
been able to clearly remember what he
looks like outside of my dream but I'll
get back to that in a minute so usually
this man just shows up in random
situations in my dream like he might be
delivering me this package or if I'm
having a test dream he'll be the teacher
if I'm being chased in my dream he's
usually the malevolent pursuer if it's
getting walked in on dream he tends to
be the one to catch me so he always
plays that kind of role I don't think
I've ever held a conversation with him
in any of these I can't really remember
him talking at all to be honest so that
brings me to today I'm flying out of
Denver for work and the flight gets
delayed because of inclement weather
it's early morning and I'm tired so I
decided to nod off for a bit in the
airport now I can never remember the
beginning of my dream but
the first thing I remember was watching
my son play jak and daxter and quick
backstory I met my kid was really into
the Last of Us so I recently dug out my
old ps2 and introduced him to jak and
daxter because they're made by the same
studio and you really took a liking to
it I don't know if other people have
this happen in their dreams but I have a
lot of dreams where I'll be watching a
movie or playing a game and I kind of
gradually become one of the characters
I'm assuming I'm not the only one who
gets that so I'm in this game and I'm
exploring this area called Misty Island
I think I was supposed to be finding
this Power Cell or something I don't
remember the exact details of the
objective but me and my son were both
inside the game he kept running ahead to
explore and I would try to keep close to
him because the name of the island
suggests it was very hazy and I was
afraid he was going to get lost or
something was going to happen to him the
problem is I kept slipping on the gravel
underneath my feet it was becoming a
challenge to even stay upright he was
just kind of running around carelessly
and I lost him for a minute as he ran
around this cliff I sprinted to catch up
with him well when I came around the
cliff there was nothing there I was not
only worried about my son getting lost
but also the threat of lurkers which if
you're not familiar with the game those
are their creepy purple reptilian
creatures with yellow eyes almost on cue
one of his creatures crawled out of the
cliff side crossed right in front of me
stopping me in my tracks it continued
onward towards the shore and disappeared
in the fog
and I notice someone's standing far in
the distance shrouded in fog I called
out my son's name but he didn't respond
he was just standing still staring at
the water I begin to run up towards him
when alert the bounding from the trees
jumped and struck him in the head before
scampering off my heart sank in my chest
and I sprinted with everything I had
when I reached him I discovered it was
not my son but rather no it couldn't be
what I saw laying there in the sand was
the man from my dreams only in video
game polygon form somehow his appearance
was even creepier and compressed
textures and ps2 graphics yet the injury
to his head was terrifyingly realistic
his body then compressed into green deco
in the typical fashion of video game
death animations and he was gone I
progressed to the area that is
essentially the end of the level where I
saw my son standing up on the platform
waiting for me as I got closer I noticed
there was someone else standing there as
well I'm sure enough it was the man
again he had his hand on my son shoulder
and they're both just staring at me not
knowing what to do I froze in my tracks
before I could come to a decision
I was jolted out of the game I was back
in my son's room staring at the blank
screen I looked over to the chair my son
had been sitting in what I saw was the
chord from his controller stretched
across the chair like he got enough and
was sitting as far back as the cable
length would allow him
I followed the stretched cable with my
eyes to meet my son's gaze but I was
instead met with
an adult pair of hands dropped the
plastic controller to the floor it was
him he was just grinning at me with the
most insane stare I was startled nearly
falling back out of my chair my first
instinct was to swing my feet around and
stumble out of the room I ran down the
hall the house seemed to be empty but
strangely all of the doors in every room
were open I looked over my shoulder as I
turned the corner he'd grown about nine
feet tall and his eyes were deadlocked
on me as he ducked under the doorframe
exiting my son's room and began to make
his way in my direction I went for the
front door in typical nightmare fashion
it was locked but for whatever reason I
didn't think to just reach down on a
market I fiddled with the doorknob
anxiously as I looked over my shoulder
and saw the man walking around the
corner and coming for me with that
creepy grin on his face the door not
fell to the ground just thinking broken
off or something as a last ditch effort
I reared back and just kicked the door
in
what happened next is sort of difficult
to put into words I was in the car just
driving as fast as I could
within reason it was a lot like the
phenomenon I explained earlier where at
first I was watching the video game and
then we are gradually in it in this case
I started off alone in the car but at
some point I realized I was in the car
with that guy I know it doesn't make
sense
but in the context of the dream I didn't
question it it wasn't making any moves
or anything literally he was just
sitting there with this stupid grin but
as time went on I was just getting more
nervous that he was about to do
something
I kept looking over at him looking back
at the road then back at him I was
trying to keep an eye on him to make
sure he wasn't going anywhere
him the road him the road the next time
I looked back at him he was breathing
more and more heavily I was getting
nervous my palms were sweaty I looked
back at the road to find I'd run out of
Road I was about to drive over the edge
into the water I slammed on the brakes
but it was too late I broke through the
barrier and propelled off the edge
shiver one of my eyes I started to wake
to my relief it was just all a crazy
dream just as I woke up a woman in
purple dress swiftly crossed in front of
me my gaze followed her to the window it
was almost white with fog it seemed that
there would be a significant delay until
we could take off just then I dropped my
bottle of water had purchased before
heading to my gate and forgotten that
I'd fallen asleep within my hand I
reached down to grab it and as I came
back up I saw something that frightened
and disturbed me the man from my dreams
he was sitting in the seat across from
me just grinning at me
number two costume shop
I know Halloween is supposed to be a
spooky holiday but my first Halloween
experience left me with scars and
nightmares for years to come
having moved to the USA when I was 17 I
had never actually celebrated Halloween
before because it wasn't even a known
holiday in my home country a few years
later when I got my first job as a
computer consultant I wanted to do
whatever I could to get ahead and move
up in the company when my boss mentioned
that there would be a company Halloween
party I saw this as an opportunity to
impress by finding the best costume in
the office I wanted to avoid the cheap
quality of pop-up Halloween stores so I
found a nice costume rental shop with
some supposedly higher quality wares I
headed over there after staying late at
work that night it was pretty far away
in the middle of nowhere but I was
hoping it would be worth the extra miles
I got in there about an hour before
clothes but to my surprise the place was
pretty much empty
there was only one customer in there
despite the fact that we were already
pretty late into October I wasn't
exactly sure what I wanted to go as so
the owner of the store helped me pick
out several costumes that I was
interested in and let me into the
changing room to see how they all looked
on me I started to get undressed when I
heard the door chime signaling that
someone was entering or leaving this was
a fairly large shop but it was small
enough that I could hear what was going
on in the front from where I was which
is why my heart sank when I heard this I
then hear a horrified scream which I
think was coming from the other customer
that was in the store with me you
against the wall I said back to the wall
now that was a different voice as far as
I could tell there were at least two men
who were operating this the entire store
was suddenly silent
that's when I heard what seemed like the
loudest gunshot I've ever heard I
literally had to cover my own mouth to
prevent myself from gasping or screaming
and tried to stay as quiet as possible
I heard the familiar sound of a cash
register opening and it was quiet for a
few moments as I could only hear people
shuffling around which I assumed was the
guy hopping over the counter and
unloading the register into a bag or
something after that there was a quieter
exchange between the first robber and
the owner of the store I couldn't hear
it very clearly but from what I could
gather the robber had asked to be taken
to the vault or something like that it
seemed like the accomplice stayed back
with the other customer and lights in
the entire store had been turned off
possibly to make it look like they were
closed from the outside I thought about
calling the police but I was afraid that
they would hear me given how quiet it
was and how well sound seemed to travel
in the store my hands were shaking as I
tried texting my roommate to ask him to
send help
but I was cut short when I heard two
pairs of footsteps headed in my
direction
they sent me into a panic since I had
left a couple of items on the floor the
door to the dressing room was a thin
swinging door with diagonal
upward-facing slots so that I could see
out to the ceiling but someone on the
outside would only be able to see part
of the floor if they tried to peek in as
quickly and quietly as possible I
gathered up everything from the floor
and moved it onto the bench I picked my
feet up onto the bench and tried to
squeeze myself into the corner there is
a small slot under the door not enough
to fit through but enough that you could
see if someone's feet were on the ground
from the other side I was able to see
two pairs of shoes walk right past my
door while I tried not to breathe they
seemed to go into the back somewhere so
I decided to finish my text message and
hope that my roommate would notice and
contact the police for me this is before
I knew that some call centers allow you
to send a text message to 911 one
directly which is now recommended for
situations that are too dangerous to
talk I was so nervous as I waited for
about 15 minutes while the owner and the
robber were somewhere in the back at no
point during this experience was I ever
comfortable but there was a point where
I kind of got used to the situation
my heart rate seemed to slow down a
little bit then out of nowhere this came
from the back of the store because this
happened after several minutes of
complete silence I nearly had a heart
attack when it happened and fell off the
bench I was praying that the other
robber didn't hear that because I was
convinced that the store owner was dead
and I would be next if they found out
about me the robber then walked back
past my changing room i sat there in
shock thinking that I might be the lone
survivor of this crime with any luck but
whatever hope I did have was dashed when
I heard what he said next the rest of
the story I didn't dare move a muscle as
I heard the two men methodically taking
apart at the rest of the store I thought
back to when the store owner had let me
into the changing room how he had to
unlocked a door to let me go in I
thought maybe just maybe that they would
assume that the doors are locked at all
times and leave it be but again my head
started burning when I saw a figure
standing right outside my door through
the slots trying to peek inside he tried
the door handle and started loudly
banging on the door he then starts
throwing himself against the door like a
madman literally see the door breaking
off its hinges before my eyes it's not
gonna take much more abuse finally
[Music]
I hear the guy yell out let's go and
they both run for the exit the rest of
the night was pretty much a blur to me I
remember the police arriving me being
marched back through the store seeing
police and ambulance lights seeing the
bloody mess made along the wall probably
from that first customer I was taken in
for questioning I probably wasn't very
helpful considering that I never saw
their faces as far as I know neither of
them were ever caught it's pretty
obvious to me why they decided to steal
from a small costume shop just before
Halloween but I still wonder why they
felt the need to kill especially someone
in my position who didn't even see their
faces
I've had many nightmares about the
incident and I struggled to get the idea
out of my head ever since I've tried
talking to therapists and friends about
the situation and people have come up
with their own theories the best and
probably most haunting theory that I've
heard so far came from a witness who
worked at a nearby restaurant and was
getting off his shift around the time
that I was in the costume store that
night after hearing about what happened
in the news he theorized that the two
criminals didn't do it for the money
but rather did it for the thrill I don't
know if there's any truth to this but he
said he noticed two men in tuxedos walk
into the shop wearing animal masks
number three heartbreaker the
stereotypical version of Valentine's Day
has always gotten on my nerves for one
the ads never show gay couples and I
tend to get asked out by guys who don't
believe I'm actually gay
this year wasn't different by much I had
to sit through class which I spent
texting my girlfriend Amy going over our
plans for the night our LGBTQ friends
were having a dinner party and we agreed
to go as I was getting up to leave after
class one of the guys walked over to me
I don't know who he is he's one of the
quiet guys who sits in the back he
handed me a heart-shaped note reading
will you be mine I sighed noticing his
friend nervously watching in the back
obviously his friend was asking sorry
but I have a girlfriend I tried to be
nice about it he went back to his friend
and I could feel a cold glare following
me I'm used to guys being rude so I
shrugged it off I went home and got
ready for the night it felt like
something was staring at me from outside
and in the shadows the feeling came back
on and off throughout the night the
party was amazing lots of laughs and
booze
everyone was intoxicated especially Amy
as I drove her home there was a car
following us I could feel my hair
standing on end
every time we passed an intersection I
would look back to see if it would turn
it finally turned when we were two
blocks from Amy's I helped her inside
and she complained constantly that it
was hot in her apartment so I opened the
window of it most people would have made
out and proceeded to make a love to
their partner at this point but I have
more dignity than that I gave her a kiss
goodnight and left it was strangely
quiet on my way home the feeling of
being followed was finally gone replaced
by an uneasy
feeling in my gut maybe the alcohol was
finally kicking in I got back to my dorm
and cracked the window open the night
air felt good on my warm face and
soothed my upset stomach I decided to
take a shot of whiskey before going to
bed as I laid there I thought I could
hear at the door rattle it was probably
my imagination
the shot I took couldn't have hit me
that hard then again that's also
probably the alcohol I wasn't sure but I
thought I could see the shadow of feet
from underneath the door I could have
sworn something hit the window but it
was probably just the wind the morning
light hit my eyes and the onset of a
hangover made my head throb the slight
smell of blood may be grown it shouldn't
be that time yes I got up just to make
sure instead of be expected the rug felt
wet under my feet and I discovered up
hearts on the floor there was a knife
through it and blood staining my rug my
heart was pounding as the metallic smell
flooded my senses the breath caught in
my throat of my stomach twisted I got up
and rushed to the bathroom the shock of
it all made me sick
literally I took a moment to drink some
water after painfully emptying the
contents of my stomach hoping to ease
the sense of dread knotting it I went
back pausing outside my door it had been
a long time since I last grade and right
now I was praying that it was nothing
praying that it was a delusion I opened
the door and it was still there I
couldn't stop myself from gagging and
that's when I saw the writing the wall
had blood smeared on it reading
now you keep in mind little police came
and they couldn't find any evidence of
forced entry no trace of who did it was
left behind I found out that the heart
belongs to Amy and it was determined
that they entered through the window I'm
not sure how anyone could climb three
storeys from the outside of the building
but now I never leave the window open at
night it's been two years now and I even
moved to a different city because of
rumors that I killed Amy a new start was
supposed to be a good thing until I
found a heart-shaped note under my door
reading your mine number four I found
some disturbing pictures in my child's
backpack my wife and I first decided to
send our daughter Ella to preschool when
my wife went back to school to get her
nursing degree Ella was about four years
old at the time and we were primarily
concerned that she would have a hard
time fitting in since all the other kids
in the class had been together for a
couple of years already at that point
the first couple of weeks went off
without a hitch or at least we didn't
notice any issues until one afternoon in
September when Ella wasn't feeling well
and went to bed right after we picked
her up from school she had her backpack
dumped right next to the door and my
wife commented on the fact that it was
surprisingly heavy considering how small
the baguette was we were curious about
what exactly they had given her that
would make the backpack so heavy so we
decided to pop it open and take a look
all that we had given her when she
started preschool were the basics
pencils markers crayons a pad of paper
extra clothes perhaps a couple other
things that I'm forgetting right now but
the point is we were very surprised to
see what we found in the backpack
it was filled to the brim with loose
papers it was a complete mess almost as
if she had just stuffed the backpack
full of paper one sheet at a time there
must have been hundreds of sheets in
there if not more the strangest thing is
Ella had never really been a very messy
child she keeps her room clean for the
most part and she's the kind of girl who
never
likes to get her hands messy naturally
and my wife and I emptied out the
backpack and tried to sort through the
mass what we found were mostly drawings
the typical stuff you would expect from
a young girl with the grass at the
bottom and the Sun in the top corner of
the page
most of the drawings had three
characters who I can only assume are
suppose to be Ella my wife and I most
were repeats or some variation of this
basic formula the three of us standing
in front of a house the three of us
standing flowers at the beach etc etc
not all the pages were drawings some of
them just contains black transcripts all
over the place it looked almost as if
she was trying to color the page black I
remember doing that when I was bored in
school as a kid as well so I wasn't too
concerned until I saw that there were
more of them subsequent pages contained
less black scribbles and more whitespace
and all of the lines seem to be
completely random from what I can tell
we said something about getting her a
bigger folder and continued to sift
through our daughter's drawings for a
while until my wife got a call and I got
hungry and went to go grab some from the
fridge after that the issue never really
came up again for the next month or so
we got busy with life and well if you
have kids you know how parenting can be
anyways one afternoon in October I was
in Ella's room getting her ready for bed
when she had to use the restroom so I
continued to sit in there and wait for
her when I noticed another messy stack
of papers we have a little table set up
in her room that she can use for her
arts and crafts and once again there was
a huge surplus of drawings pouring out
of her backpack I was starting to wonder
if they'd do anything else at this
preschool of hers besides his free time
to color when I noticed something
strange there was a new character added
to the family portrait and he looked
disturbing to say the least
he was a tall slim bald man wearing long
white robes this figure was completely
devoid of any color except for the eyes
and mouth which were scribbled in a dark
red it looked like she had jammed the
crown into the page as hard as she could
to produce the eyes and mouth resulting
in a much more intense pigment in those
areas other than that this character and
the areas surrounding his outline were
the only parts of the page that were
completely colorless what was even more
disturbing was the fact that this
character and my wife were frowning
while Ella and I both had huge smiles on
our faces it just didn't sit well with
me I continued to look through her
drawings and found that this fourth
person was in every drawing as I flipped
through them I noticed this guy's name
to be staring at my wife in some of the
drawings he seemed to be standing behind
her I was legitimately creeped out by
this but told myself that it must be an
imaginary friend or something I
continued to flip through the pages and
ended up coming across more of those
black scribbles but these ones were what
I can really only describe as more
violent more intense it was the same
thing where it looked like she had
matched the Kranitz of the page at this
point I was able to look past what I had
seen but what I saw next gave me a deep
pit in my stomach she had drawn pictures
of my wife laying at the bottom of the
ocean her eyes were scribbled out in
black cran and she was wearing a huge
frown to my own dismay this wasn't the
only drawing like this she had drawn the
same picture over and over and over my
jaw hung a gape as I tried to comprehend
what I was looking at when I realized
that my wife in the bath right now Ella
had probably gone into that same
bathroom before I could react I heard a
cold voice from behind
radar you Dearing I turned to see Ella
standing at the door I tried asking her
about the pictures but she just refused
to talk about it and climbed in Tibet
and this wasn't just a case of kids will
be kids
she had a most serious tone about her
thankfully my wife didn't mention that
anything could happen while they were in
the bathroom
but we were unable to get Ella to
respond to any of our questions about
the pictures now worth considering
seeking professional help
number five the Scarecrow I'll always
remember seventh grade Halloween that's
one of the last good innocent years of
trick-or-treating with my friends before
the paradigm shift to haunted houses
parties [ __ ] costumes boys and alcohol
I'll also remember it though for one
other reason that I haven't been able to
erase from my mind since that night I
remember that day
it was Friday so almost everyone wore
their costumes to school Jane Margaret
and I have decided to go as the
Powerpuff Girls
even though the show was a long since
irrelevant at the time Jane was bubbles
Margaret went as buttercup and I being
the only one without the correct hair
color or a red wig to become blossom
during homeroom everyone showing off
their costumes one of our guy friends
Chris was the only one who didn't wear
his costume to school Chris was one of
the more popular guys that we knew so I
found it kind of strange that he hadn't
dressed up when Margaret asked him why
he didn't win her costume he just told
us that we'd have to stop by his place
tonight if we wanted to see his costume
we got the idea that whatever he was
wearing was obviously too graphic to be
brought to school and made plans to
swing by and check it out sometime that
evening by the time we made it to
Chris's house it was starting to get
pretty late and I figured we had about
an hour so if trick-or-treating left
before we had to call it a night we were
a bigger group of girls now probably six
or seven of us all in costume his house
didn't seem to have much in terms of
decoration just a few of those Halloween
store cobwebs you see on the porch and a
scarecrow sitting on the bench near the
front door someone rang the bell and
Chris's mom showed up Justin regular
clothes with a witch hat which I'm
pretty sure she wore on multiple years
as a picked out candy marker asked of
Krista's home but his mom told us that
he had gone out to scare some
trick-or-treaters with a couple friends
I was the last one in line to take a
piece of candy so I thanked her and we
went on our way as I walked back to the
sidewalk I felt something behind me but
tug on my wig pulling it off my head a
little bit I looked back and I saw the
Scarecrow Stern just a couple inches
behind me a couple of the girls thought
out screams as well when they turned
around I noticed the Scarecrow had moved
from the bench and snuck up behind us
Margaret seemed to be the first one to
come to realization that it was Chris
who had dressed up and waited for us
inside the Scarecrow when Jane asked how
long he had to wait there he didn't say
anything and just stared at us which
admittedly made me a little bit
uncomfortable but I tried not to show it
not wanting to give the Nonna prankster
any satisfaction I guess he didn't want
to break character because even as we
invited him to come trick-or-treat at a
few more houses he remained silent for
the rest of the time Jane and I poked
fun at him trying too hard to be mr.
creepy mysterious trying to get him to
crack or laugh or something but it
didn't work he just followed us from
house to house for another block or so
until we all decided to go back to my
house and hang out for a while he would
occasionally tug on my wig but I tried
not to react because I knew that was
exactly what he wanted so we stayed up
late seeing as how tomorrow was a
Saturday and we could sleep in as long
as we wanted one of the girls went home
but the rest of us had been Chris stayed
up to watch a scary movie which ended up
not being so scary Chris didn't even
seem to want to watch the movie he just
stared at us the entire time I knew he
was just trying to freak me out so I
ignored him and tried to pay attention
to the movie I was bored I fell asleep
about 20 minutes in when I woke up it
was around 3:00 in the morning and
when I was passed out on the couch Chris
however was gone I figured that he
wouldn't be able to mess with us anymore
and walked home when we got back to
school on Monday we confronted Chris
that is all stunts on Halloween
he got this confused expression on his
face and told us that his family didn't
own a scarecrow or a scarecrow costume
and that he had been out all evening -
protruding with his friends he even
showed us a picture of his group with
him wearing a Jeff the killer costume he
seemed to have no idea what we were
talking about when we brought up this
Care crow a couple of his friends even
served as his alibis saying that they
were with Chris the entire night to this
day I don't know if this is an elaborate
prank or if some stranger actually
followed us around all night but what
really bothers me most to think about is
the possibility that this guy came into
my house and after all of us were asleep
left without taking anything or saying a
word I've never seen that particular
scarecrow costume again and to this day
I've never gotten Chris to admit that he
was behind it number six my sleep
paralysis amplified I started my new job
a few days ago well to be entirely
accurate it's not a new job I just got
transferred to another branch in another
time zone my doctor says that the stress
of having a new job new schedule and new
life are all probably contributing to my
severe sleep issues and hallucinations
I've been having okay maybe I'm getting
ahead of myself here let me take a step
back my name is Alex I'm 28 years old
and single I work for a pretty sizable
company that sells consumer and
professional-grade amplifiers to
musicians I'm the guy who makes sure
yeah
to get the thing he ordered and get it
on time it was recently decided that it
would be a good idea for people like me
to be close to the people who are
selling these products why they didn't
realize that in the first place beyond
me but recently I found myself packing
up and moving across the country so I
was kind of annoyed about the whole
relocation thing for the first ten
minutes of the new office I was supposed
to be meeting some of these salespeople
who I would now be working alongside
enter Caitlin luminescent light brown
eyes short but not too short brunette
hair dimples to die for I quickly got
over any annoyance I had with having to
move and started to think I was going to
like this new office by the end of the
first day Caitlin and I already had at
least three inside jokes see I told you
the copy machine outsmarted Lenny I told
her as I headed out for the day don't
worry you're not supposed to get it it's
one of our inside jokes she laughed and
told me she'd see me tomorrow she had
such a cute laugh sorry I got distracted
there for a second at the end of the day
I was exhausted famished
I was so eager to retire to bed but when
I laid down and shut my eyes I just
couldn't fall asleep I kept opening my
eyes and looking at the clock 1 o'clock
2 o'clock 2:30
why wasn't I falling asleep was it this
new bed was it this new apartment I
looked around my new pad and thought
about how funny it was that I still
always close my bedroom door despite
being the only one here now old habits
do die hard I suppose maybe I couldn't
sleep because I was thinking too much
maybe Caitlin was on my mind too
eventually at some point I must have
dozed off but when I awoke it was still
dark out out of the corner of my eye I
saw the clock 4:23 in the morning I was
feeling pretty thirsty so I hopped up to
grab some water only when I hopped up to
grab some water my body didn't move an
inch
come to think of it I hadn't moved at
all since I had woken up I immediately
felt a wave of terror crash over me what
was going on why can't I move what
with me I was instantly overcome with
anxiety and discomfort it was like a
nightmare where nothing happens but it
was a nightmare
because nothing was happening what if I
was stuck like this forever I will think
to come check on me what if I starve to
death like this what if what if the next
thing I remember was me waking up the
next morning to my relief I was able to
get up and hit the alarm clock now what
was that last night
some kind of weird dream or was it real
it felt real but it doesn't seem real I
brought my own lunch to work that day I
opened up the fridge to find it it's
completely stuffed I couldn't find an
open spot anywhere so I start to
rearrange stuff to make room what are
you doing
I hear from behind me I turned to see
this guy Jerry standing there Jerry is
the head of the sales department every
office has that guy right from what I
could tell so far in my one day here
Jerry is the guy who makes you want to
take the stairs when you see him waiting
for the elevator and I might be speaking
from experience already I was just
hooked my food in your hand he asked in
the most accusatory manner I've ever
heard in my life he snatched the bag for
me I was just trying to make space so
that I could fit my lunch yeah ok he
walked away
hey no complaint from me and now I had a
spot to put my lunch in throughout the
day I made sure to visit Caitlin and
make sure she wasn't overworking herself
sometimes people forget to take little
breaks I was just looking out for my
fellow employee the lack of sleep the
night before had me all worn out I was
positive that this time I would
have no trouble whatsoever with passing
out I shut my bedroom door behind me I'm
literally collapsed on my bed I
continued to lie awake for a while
though I looked at my clock periodically
11:17 12:03 12:15 1217 I was growing
restless I guess at some point though I
knocked out because a couple of hours
later I woke up in the middle of the
night again great I tried to look at the
clock but I couldn't see it from the
position I was in that's when I realized
it had happened again I couldn't move
once again I was overcome with fear was
this gonna become a regular thing
however what I saw next was about to
take my fear and amplify it my door was
open and this creature was standing in
the doorway
it was humanoid but its body was all
pitch black and it was probably seven or
eight feet tall its head it was shaped
like the top of a tree stump that had
been struck by lightning and its eyes
were glowing red its mouth opening
represented a polygon with completely
random angles but the scariest part to
me for whatever reason was its fingers
each one was long in branch like
probably about two feet in length
they were just dangling there and he
well it was moving them around in a wave
motion I tried to move I tried to scream
but what I found is that I could not
even do that
it started to pace towards my bed
I could not even describe to you the
motion that used to walk it reached the
foot of the bed I was fighting with
every ounce of energy I had but my body
would not budge it came along the side
of the bed and continued to inch closer
to me I tried to scream for help and
just managed to get out the slightest
sound help I screamed out as I sat up it
was morning again I was left with the
mystery of what the sleep paralysis was
I decided it was time to see a doctor
about it and made an appointment for
after work I wasn't going to let my
rough night ruin my perfect day however
today I had a plan when I got to work
Jerry was waiting for the elevator I
smoothly redirected myself towards the
stairs and I could almost feel him
sneering at my back by the time I made
it up the stairs
Jerry was talking to Caitlin about
something luckily I saw him walk away as
I walked up I stopped and said hello to
Caitlin she flashed her infectious smile
at me sure I was tired but things were
going well I didn't bring my lunch to
work today instead when it got to my
break time I have one over to Caitlin's
desk and invited her to go grab some
food with me she delightfully accepted
we got sandwiches and we totally headed
off we were talking and cracking jokes
the entire time she does this little
thing where she'll get excited about
something and kind of bite her lip it's
incredible we got back to the office and
she offered me a mint from her drawer I
accepted so she went to open the little
box of mints and accidentally spilled a
bunch of them on the desk we both
reached for the loose mints I saw my
chance and grabbed her hand and held it
in mine here relax I'll take care of
this I told her and used my other hand
to gather the mints
what's going on here I heard the stern
voice that belong to Jerry as he walked
up she quickly pulled her hands away I
finished gathering up the mints and
after taking one for myself deposited
the rest back in the container I was
taken aback by what she said next
she told him hey babe we just got back
from lunch my heart sank deep into my
chest and my head started burning up did
my ears deceive me did she really just
call Jerry the prick of the office and
her boss babe surely this must be a joke
a cruel meme of some kind he came up
behind her and kissed the top of her
head crushing whatever hope I had left
and glaring at me as he did so I
couldn't believe it how is this idiot
better than me I felt myself starting to
blush I felt so stupid thinking she was
into me she was just being friendly how
did I not see this coming
uh I gotta get back to work she thanked
me for my company at lunch as I turned
away I could feel his glare on me so
strongly that I wish I'd worn sunscreen
you went out to lunch with that guy
I heard him ask her with an attitude as
I fled the scene great three days and I
was already making enemies the rest of
my afternoon was so hard to get through
I was constantly dozing off at my desk
not enough to fully fall asleep mind you
just enough to feel about as miserable
as I felt rejected I wanted to just go
home and sleep but I had my doctor's
appointment that evening the doc
confirmed what I pretty much already
knew I had sleep paralysis one in every
12 people get it or something he
questioned me about my lifestyle and
when he found out I had just made a big
move he was almost positive that was the
reason for my issues psychological
stress and abnormal sleep cycles are
apparently the two biggest factors that
usually contribute to it he told me that
the hallucinations are a common symptom
basically my body thinks it's a slave
ball it's awake I was supposed to see a
psychiatrist if the problem persisted
once I'd settled into my new routine
not exactly the treatment I was hoping
for but it was somewhat reassuring that
he expected me to recover on my own that
night I actually had a better time
falling asleep than before I must have
been out by 11 or 12 but that didn't
stop me from waking up in the middle of
the night again unable to move unable to
speak officially knowing that I suffered
from sleep paralysis didn't make the
experience any less scary when you have
it it feels like you're never gonna wake
up from it and the things you see feel
incredibly real and you feel incredibly
helpless that's why I wanted to scream
when I saw a knife-wielding silhouette
in my doorframe the man stepped forward
and caught a little bit of moonlight
just enough for me to identify who it
was Jerry as per usual he did not look
happy to see me he tiptoed across the
room to the foot of my bed and stared me
down with disgust he continued to look
at me for about two full minutes
his body was trembling finally he came
around to the side of the bed taking an
almost identical path to the creature
from the night before he raised the
knife in the air gripping it so hard I
could see the loss of circulation to his
fingers he froze in that position almost
like he was waiting for me to make the
first move I couldn't take it the
anxiety was killing me I just wanted him
to do it already and get it over with
the last thing I could remember them as
him stuck in that position trembling
like a maniac morning came I turned off
my alarm clock and the post nightmare
relief felt incredible as it dawned on
me I actually felt pretty decent for
once not back to where I was before the
moon but not 100% exhausted either it
was Friday
so I thought maybe I'd have the energy
to go out into town and explore my new
city after work tonight
maybe it would help get my mind off
things I hopped out of bed and as I
began to get dressed I realized
something
something that flushed whatever optimism
or relief I had away something that made
my body and legs lock up just as they
had the two previous night's something
that made my heart sink deep into my
chest just as it had when I found out
about Kaitlyn and Jerry what I realized
was my bedroom door was open number
seven play with me are you awake
why are you hiding I don't mean you any
harm I know it's late but I want to play
you haven't picked me up for nearly a
month I want to have tea with you again
I promise not to spill I didn't know it
was hot sorry it ruined your favorite
shirt I'm happy to have tea and eat
biscuits with you today your eyes are
beautiful with that dress I wish I had
such lovely eyes don't turn away from me
why are you ignoring me is it because
you don't love me like your other dolls
[Music]
cries and scratches in the night
[Music]
please don't fret you only want to play
with you we can be best friends forever
I'll never leave you I thought you were
lonely isn't that why you have so many
dolls you hugged me and loved me now why
do you hate me
we have lots of fun together is my hair
too knotted or my dress too dirty I know
it's late but will you play with me one
last time I hate seeing you cry you can
play hide and seek you hide and I'll see
if you win you can do whatever you want
with me and I promise to behave if
and you have to play with me when I want
to play I'm glad you're letting me out
to play this time I promise not to
disappoint don't worry I won't peek not
one bit
be quick
[Music]
[Music]
they are not I'm coming for you where
are you are you in the closet I thought
I heard a door close no okay
perhaps you went downstairs I can't wait
to find you if you go all the way to the
basement careful you know you're not
supposed to play down here oh you chose
that dog the one that was made for us to
play in together happy that you thought
of me now we can be together forever
don't worry no one will find us here I
make sure that the door is locked and
now to nuts what's that you're hungry we
don't have another tea party what do you
mean no I don't know how long it's been
[Music]
it's time to play why are you so I can
find one answer me why are you ignoring
me again it's been a long time since you
move smells like something's rotting why
did you have to die dark and cold but I
won't believe you never will
number eight creepy clown school
lockdown as a kid I never really
understood why some of my classmates
were afraid of clowns I didn't really
find them scary not that I found them
funny either most of them just looked
kind of goofy and dumb I remember having
this exact argument with my best friend
Kevin at the lunch tables in elementary
his argument was always that I needed to
see the movie it's in order to
understand but being in second grade at
the time my parents would never let me
watch it
I actually remember on Halloween some of
the older kids in the neighborhood had
dressed up as clowns and went around
scaring trick-or-treaters maybe I just
had thick skin but I remember one of
them chasing our entire friend with her
being left on the sidewalk laughing at
their expense but anyways this story
takes place in November that second
grade year just after Halloween we were
sitting in math class boring as ever
when situations like this arise which
were quite often during math Kevin and I
would meet in the bathroom and trade
baseball cards we had a system one of us
would give the signal and we would
stagger our bathroom requests as not to
raise suspicion from our teacher on this
particular occasion
Kevin had gone off to the bathroom first
and I gave it a good five minutes before
raising my hand as I was waiting to be
called on our teacher mr. Davis was
interrupted by the sound of the intercom
which was strange because they usually
only did announcements at the beginning
and end of the day at this time we are
conducting in the internal lockdown this
is not a drill please initiate lockdown
at this time our teacher was pretty calm
with his response walking over to the
door and locking it he told us all the
line up against the back wall and keep
quiet as he crossed the room to pull
down the blinds I figured he had been
through many lockdown drills before and
this probably wasn't anything big we had
a lockdown at my old school once and it
turned out to be a parent who just
forgot to sign in we waited like that
for about five minutes
one kid asked mr. Davis how much longer
would be and he got a hard from our
teacher signalling that no talking would
be tolerated it was about this time when
I remember that Kevin was still in the
bathroom I debated in my head on whether
I should bring this to the teachers
attention but it was ultimately too
scared after seeing that other kid get
scolded for making a peep that might
sound kind of ridiculous given the
circumstances but keep in mind I was
only seven years old at the time and I
was still very intimidated by Authority
we waited in silence for a little while
longer
with each minute that passed this
situation got more tense I started to
feel anxiety butterflies in my stomach
that's when there was another
announcement on the intercom
[Music]
[Applause]
this circus music started playing over
the intercom
and then after that there was what
sounded like laughter in the background
one of the girls in the class asked mr.
Davis what was going on he told her to
keep quiet but his voice cracked and he
stuttered in saying so that may have
actually been the scariest part of the
whole ordeal for me being a kid and
seeing in adults and on top of that
someone who you're supposed to feel safe
with being visibly shaken like that it
was terrifying I guess I wasn't the only
one who felt that way I could hear
sniffles coming from one of the other
kids like they had been crying abruptly
the music just stopped we were all
sitting on the floor in a line in the
corner of the room I actually closed my
eyes as if that would somehow help me
but nothing could block out the
breathing that I heard blaring over the
school intercom until it stopped we sat
in silence for a while longer
hearts racing minds racing faster the
silence was broken by a slant for a
group of screams the sound traveled from
down the hall at this I opened my eyes
to see mr. Davis jump up and push the
big wooden teacher's desk from across
the room
I noticed tears streaming down his
cheeks as he did so I started to feel
sick to my stomach as the anxiety
continued to build footsteps approached
from down the hallway
they stopped near our door I could see a
shadow on the wall
someone was standing out there I could
tell by the shape that it was the shadow
of a clown after a short pause it seemed
like the shadow had disappeared and I
started to feel a little bit of relief
that the clown had walked away there was
a bang on the door and suddenly standing
at the door window was a terrifying
looking clown with bright white
facepaint a huge cartoony Timothy smile
painted on his face to contrast the cold
evil looking smirk on his actual lips he
was somewhat overweight and were a big
baggy clown suit the whole class
screamed as he repeatedly tried to open
the door we went from trying to wiggle
the doorknob free to moving back and
trying to kick in the wooden door the
glass screaming each time he did so it
realistically didn't last too long
before he gave up and moved on but it
felt like forever to me at the time that
was the last we saw of the mysterious
lockdown clown but in all of the
hysteria
I completely forgot about Kevin the
lockdown lasted for another 20 minutes
or so until each room was cleared they
made the announcement over the intercom
telling us the lockdown was over and
teachers could resume classes they
didn't actually ever say what happened
probably not wanting to raise any panic
a few minutes later Kevin appeared at
the door and looked like an absolute
wreck his hair was literally standing up
on end he had dark circles around his
eyes and tears streaming down his face
his entire body was shaking I'd never
seen someone looking so disheveled class
was once again interrupted so that our
teacher could escort Kevin to the nurse
he didn't come back to class after that
and his parents ended up holding him out
of school for a full three weeks to
recover he came back just before winter
break I asked him what happened a couple
of times but he always just told me that
he didn't want to talk about it he ended
up coming to school for the rest of
second semester before his family moved
away at the start of that summer he was
just never quite the same after that
we never got an official story on what
happened only a swirl of rumors that the
intruder had never actually been found I
shuddered to think about what would have
happened if mr. Davis hadn't pushed the
desk up along the door anyways
I remembered about this story all these
years later because I often suspected it
was parked on the way home from the bus
station
they had a carnival going on over the
weekend it was closed now but it was
about 2:00 a.m. as I cut through the
fairground one of the ticket booths had
a light that had been left on the only
light in the entirety of the area for
that matter and that's when I saw the
clown crash up against the glass and
stare at me with those wide eyes and may
have been just some teenagers or
youtubers pulling a prank but I ran as
fast as I could
and didn't stop until I was locked
inside of my room because clowns terrify
me now number 9 Jason this is a story
that took place six months ago when my
first son Elliot had just turned five
years old
Jason was first introduced into our
lives when we decided to hold off
sending Elliot to kindergarten since his
birthday was so close to the cutoff we
decided it would be best for him to go
start school as one of the older kids in
class as opposed to the youngest so when
he started talking to Jason we felt we
had made the right decision
Jason is Elliot's imaginary friend I
can't imagine how the other
kindergarteners would have reacted to
the idea of an imaginary friend so it
seemed like starting a bit later would
give him time to go through this phase
and be ready for school next fall the
first time I can remember hearing about
Jason was one evening just as we were
finishing up dinner Elliot had requested
to take some food up to his room to give
to Jason Julianna inquisitively asked
him who Jason was to which he replied my
friend who lives in the closet upstairs
Juliana granted him permission to take
the rest of his food up as long as he
promised to come clean the dish before
he went off to bed I shot her a look but
she being the free-willed spirit that
she has ignored me until Elliot had run
up the steps I don't think it was a good
idea to encourage
kind of behavior but she assured me that
having an imaginary friend was totally
normal and that it would be a good idea
to humor him until he was ready to grow
out of it on his own
hesitantly I agreed and eventually I
would talk to Elliott about Jason on a
day to day basis eventually I learned
how to use Jason to my advantage for
example when Elliott didn't want to get
in the car to go to the dentist I would
tell him that Jason said he wanted to go
to the dentist and that Elliott should
come at times
Elliott would hardly mention Jason at
all other times it seemed that Jason was
all he wanted to talk about one time we
caught him taking snacks from the
kitchen and he claimed that they were
for Jason Juliana wisely let this slide
and later told me that if this was the
only way that we could get Elliott to
eat it was okay with her and after many
long battles at the dinner table I was
quick to agree I would oftentimes hear
Elliott in his room talking to Jason and
I wondered how long this phase would
last at one point I asked him what Jason
looked like and he told me that he wore
a black snow hat and had a long fuzzy
beard
I was taken off-guard by this since I
had always imagined that Elliot's idea
of Jason was a kid his age I brought
this up with Juliana and she assured me
that it was perfectly normal for a kid
to have an adult as an imaginary friend
after all we are both adults and he
spends most of his time with us so it
makes sense that he would see an adult
as his friend she even said that her
younger sister had an imaginary friend
as a kid who was supposedly an old man
named event which she thinks as a result
of them having spent a lot of time at
their grandparents house back then I had
never had an imaginary friend or any
siblings so I just had to take my wife's
word on all of this that is until one
day that changed everything and still
makes me paranoid we have just gotten
back from the Italian restaurant one of
the only decent places that
can get Elliott to eat at on a constant
basis we parked in the driveway and
decided to go for a short walk since it
was pretty nice out that evening
normally we come into the house through
the garage but since we had gone for a
walk we entered in the front door on
this occasion as we were taking our
shoes off I heard what I thought the
sound of a cough coming from upstairs
I turned to Giuliano wondering if she
had heard it too she looked pale and
shocked as she asked me in a panic what
was that this was probably loud enough
that if someone was upstairs they might
hear Elliott told us that it was
probably just Jason I told my wife and
son to stay put and I went to
investigate when I got upstairs I went
into Elliott's room the light was on in
the window is open I searched the entire
house but was unable to find anything
the windows from Elliot's room leads
onto a section of the roof that is
pretty high up but not impossible jumped
down from we later interrogated Elliott
to see if he had left the window open
but he swore he couldn't remember we
tried to get him to tell us that Jason
was real but it was a delicate situation
we didn't want to scare him for life but
we didn't want him to be in danger
either of course at his age I don't
think he fully understood the difference
between real and pretend yet we did end
up calling the police and I half
expected them to find the proof that
someone was living in the closet but
they couldn't find any DNA that didn't
- Elliot anywhere in the room Elliot
made friends with a couple kids on the
block and he never really brings up
Jason anymore but it truly chills me to
think that someone could have been in
our house talking to our son in his room
while he slept possibly using him to
sneak food up and to be honest who knows
what else now I check all the upstairs
rooms every night before bed including
the closets and under the bed I tried to
do it when Elliot is not in the room so
he doesn't get to thinking he'll be
starting school in fall and I doubt
we'll really have any confirmation on
whether Jason was just imaginary friend
or not until he's a little bit older
Juliana and I have a second child on the
way now though so I really hope we find
out sooner rather than later
you
number ten christina grimmie final
goodbye
I've always been strangely fascinated by
tragedy now don't get me wrong it's not
like I'm happy that terrible things
happen I certainly don't encourage
terrorism or anything but I have spent
many nights on the weird side of YouTube
studying 911 videos or watching houses
get swept away by Hurricane Katrina I
think we all have a small tendency for
our eyes to be drawn to the morbid just
look at how drivers stare at the
wreckage during a highway traffic
accident and in turn slow down the
traffic themselves I also think that our
curiosity with such things as a culture
is related to our love for ghost towns I
always think it's amazing when a place
that once had so much buzz and attention
becomes barren and empty so quickly
sometimes tragedy and ghost towns can go
hand-in-hand just look at Pompeii or
Chernobyl one night in late 2016 I found
a similar example a virtual ghost town
if you will while browsing YouTube at
3:00 in the morning before going to bed
I stumbled upon a video from christina
grimmie christina was a youtube singer
who was tragically shot and killed just
after her concert in Orlando back in
June this was a truly sad and scary time
for her fans and the community christina
was just 22 years old and she was one of
the first big youtubers to pass away
since she posted so regularly I imagine
fans were left with a much bigger hole
in their lives as compared to other
celebrity deaths as I clicked through
some of her videos and read some of the
comments I can see that many of her fans
saw her as a friend and were torn apart
at her death she even used to refer to
her fanbase as her friend base I came to
think that I would have been friends
with her too
I hadn't heard about Christina until
after her untimely death but in looking
at some of her other content I started
to see what the big deal was she was a
beautiful girl with a beautiful voice
she was a self proclaimed Legend of
Zelda nerd and she even had a Death Note
tattoo
I imagine we would have gotten along
very well had we known each other
naturally I did quite a bit of digging
watching videos and reading comments
there was a lot of pain carried on that
page but in a way her channel was a lot
like a ghost town sure there are still
occasional posts from her manager
including a memorial video and some
pre-recorded music videos but for the
most part it was a ghost channel in many
ways that served as a memorial with
people leaving their condolences on her
discussion page most of the comments
were fangirls talking about how much
they miss her with the occasional why
couldn't it have been keemstar comment
but by far the most interesting thing to
me is looking at those videos uploaded
right before her death some of her final
recorded moments on camera and seeing
people's reactions now that she's gone I
don't really know what it is I feel bad
for her and her fans but these videos
just captivate my attention this led me
to start looking at some of the tribute
videos that have been made in her honor
and it's here that I stumbled upon a
playlist called christina grimmie
unlisted so I guess that christina got
her start by doing mostly covers and
some of them have since been struck down
because of copyright while others were
switched to private or unlisted in fact
most of the videos on this playlist
couldn't be watched because they were
changed to private but the rest of them
were just unlisted but what caught my
attention was one unlisted video titled
final goodbyes in all cash
with the thumbnail of Christina waving
at the camera the video was about five
minutes long as I recall and of course I
clicked on it to see exactly what this
final goodbye video was less than one
second into the video I was shocked with
what I saw it was a video of Christina
in her room
only her face was covered in what looked
like blood and she was crying her eyes
out as she talked it looked like she had
been sobbing for hours she was holding
the camera and recording herself and it
was basically just shaking all over the
place my first thought was that this was
some kind of Halloween or April Fool's
prank that she had done but I looked at
the date of the video and it said it was
uploaded today which was obviously
impossible I was in complete shock it
had only a couple hundred views and
started with her barely able to get any
words out through all the crying I can't
remember all of her exact words but she
started talking in typical vlog format
save for the fact that she was sobbing
through all of it
[Music]
I'm sorry that I had to leave me like
this she was coughing and choking on her
own words as she spoke I wish I could
stay here with every last one of you
thank you guys so much for being there
and supporting me along the way you guys
were literally the biggest part of me it
was an incredible journey and I'm so
sorry that I had to end this way I love
going unto her so much because I get to
see all of your smiling faces and no one
can take that away from me no matter
what I just wish that I had gotten one
final chance to say goodbye I guess I
wasn't alone
because when I scroll down to the
comments they were pouring in some of
them were as shocked as I was wondering
how this was even possible and trying to
analyze the situation others were just
overwhelmingly thankful for her coming
back to give them closure it seemed like
all of the comments that I saw were
positive ones
I guess because you'd have to be a fan
of her to be seeking out the video
before I got to the end of the video it
stopped playing on its own and I got the
familiar and unknown error has a current
message I tried refreshing the page but
it told me that the user had removed the
video I frantically went to her channel
to see if could be found but it was
nowhere I searched YouTube to see if
anyone had reloaded it but it couldn't
be found I even tried to find that
christina grimmie unlisted playlist but
it seemed like that was gone too
I was trying to process what had just
happened had I dozed off and imagined
that I certainly didn't think so
everything seems so real
it was so vivid that I still can't get
her face on that video out of
I was starting to think I had imagined
it somehow until I went to her channel
and looked at the discussion comments
several comments had just come in saying
things like thank you thank you for
everything no I'm I'm not really sure
number eleven
wake-up syndrome do you ever wake up in
a hotel or at a friend's house and for
those first few seconds of consciousness
not know exactly where you are like it
takes a few moments for you to realize
that you aren't in your own bed but
you've gone on vacation or that you've
passed out in a buddy's guest room this
always used to happen to me when I would
go away to summer camp as a kid it would
happen during the first week or so I
would wake up thinking I was in my own
bed at least until I opened my eyes and
came to the realization then I was in a
cabin miles away from home that same
thing would always happen during those
first couple of days home from camp I
would pop out of bed ready to go for a
hike or a kayak only to discover that my
mind had been playing tricks on me again
I don't know if there's a proper term
for this phenomenon but I'm sure that
anyone who has travelled before and
probably knows what I'm talking about
when I first started University I used
to get that feeling all the time I had
imagined I was back at home in high
school back then if I slept in too late
mom would send my sister Tara in to wake
me up
Tara was always the early riser between
the two of us on weekends you could
count on her being up before 9:00 every
day I was always more of the Nite Owl
and preferred to stay up late watching
movies and then sleep into around noon
or something but during the school week
as you can imagine how such snoozing was
allowed and Tara would be sent in to
wake me up
sometimes she would even bring our dog
me to help her out at around 15 to 20
pounds Mia was hardly a force to be
taken seriously but what made him such
an effective alarm clock was his
consistent burning desire for attention
he would jump all the way up onto my bed
run up to top of my weary body and lick
my face until finally I mustered up the
stamina to wake up and go get ready for
school the human mind really is an
amazing thing for better or worse every
week or so during my first term I would
wake up in my dorm thinking I was back
at home my old bed again I would even
hear Tara's words echo in my head before
I could peel my eyes open eventually it
stopped happening at least for the most
part I guess my mind just grew
accustomed to the fact that I'd be
staying in dorms from now on but every
now and then it still happens I'm a
sophomore now last week I had visited
home for spring break I got back to
school late last night and immediately
hit the sack before meeting up with any
of my friends and sure enough this
morning I awoke with that same old
feeling
as I slowly started to wake up my eyes
remained closed as I tried to doze back
off to sleep in my mind I was home I
even heard my sister's words that going
through my head just like old times
[Music]
wake up do you want to make it blade my
ground rolled over trying to ignore the
world around me for just a little longer
but as I started to come to her soon
realized it was all in my head now I was
back at university again Terra was not
there and I could sleep in to my heart's
content but then it happened once I
realized where I was I started to fall
back to sleep and for a short while I
was relaxed
that's when I felt me you licked my face
number 12
island adventure a woman at the airport
had asked me if I was looking forward to
my vacation to simply say yes would have
been an understatement I had to work
overtime for five months in order to
afford to get here then I had to find
time of work and get off at the same
time as my boyfriend
we had to research the perfect resort on
the perfect island with the perfect
weather but we made it nothing else was
between me the warm tropical sunshine a
cold refreshing margarita and the
relaxing sound of waves crashing on the
sand in front of me and carelessly
rolling back out into the sea as I dug
my toes into the soft sand and laid back
on my beach chair I thought about all
the possibilities that awaited us here
at the grand maritime beach resort
kayaking through the ocean breeze living
the high life at the offshore casino
backpacking the expansive rainforest by
moonlight or regenerating my body at the
luxury poolside spa maybe I'd even try
scuba diving though I wasn't sure I
liked the idea of breathing through a
tube I think before any of that though I
just kick back on the beach and enjoy
some sunlight
we'd had a long trip and it felt good to
just drop our bags slip into a bikini
and take in the saltwater aroma
I could feel myself starting to fade off
to Lucy Lucy you okay oh yeah I just
fell asleep what time is it about two
you're tired you look dead Thanks
I was just going up to the bar do you
want anything to drink you could grab me
a pina colada
I guess okay he kissed me and headed off
to the bar before I could doze off again
a strange little man came walking down
the beach with a clipboard he looked
like one of the locals a bit of an
oddball one at that he went from chair
to chair making his way up to where I
was when he arrived he asked if I was
interested in going on an island
adventure he explained that it would
include backpacking in the rainforest
ziplining roasting food by a campfire
and bathing in a private waterfall
grotto the clipboard included photos of
what looked like an absolutely amazing
time to me so I told him it looked
perfect and I wanted to sign my
boyfriend and I up for it
he told me to follow him down the beach
to the activity Shack so I can make a
reservation I dipped my feet in the
water as we strolled the length of the
shore but the man kept rushing me along
I didn't think much of it at the time
just assuming he was impatient that
should have been my first of many red
flags
next we've walked off the property of
the resort I asked if the expedition was
included in the resort package he told
me it was and I had no reason to believe
otherwise we finally get down to the
little Hut all I remember was it being
completely empty and not really looking
like an activity Shack at all the guy
quickly apologized and told me that the
activity director must have already
headed up to the site to begin preparing
for the excursion I was starting to get
pretty annoyed at this point and told
him I better walk back and let my
boyfriend know but he assured me that
the site was just across the street and
it would only be a couple more minutes I
was reluctant but didn't want to be rude
since he insisted besides it would be
good for me to get to scope out where we
would be exploring so we made our way
inland I had to run across the street
barefoot no crosswalk this led us
directly into the rainforest and when we
got there I started to get a bad feeling
there was no set path we were following
he was just leading me deeper into the
forest the other thing that set me off
at this point was the complete lack of
other tourists I thought for sure we'd
see other couples signing up as well but
scratch that it wasn't just a lack of
other tourists it was a lack of people
there was nobody out here just me and
the sky who randomly approached me on
the beach I had no real idea that he
actually worked for the resort he was
kind of scraggly and unkempt certainly
not up to the standards of grooming we
had seen at the front desk but he did
look to be an island local like most of
the employees we had seen at the resort
and it's not like the island adventure
expedition wasn't advertised in the
brochures but something deep inside me
said that this wasn't the real thing I
got more and more nervous I was honestly
thinking about turning and running
the only thing that stopped me from
doing it was how embarrassing it would
be if this was legit because there was
still some doubt in my mind besides it's
not like I'd make it very far with no
shoes and no idea where I was going I
debated doing it anyway in my head when
something emerged in the distance
another man was standing out there
veiled by a layer of fog and facing
slightly away from us relief washed over
me when the guy I was with called out to
him in another language and the guy came
up to us realistically it was just a
couple minutes just as he had told me
back at the activity shack before I
could feel silly for doubting him the
two men went back and forth in their
native tongue I don't know what they
were saying obviously but I just know
they were talking very quickly but what
was weird was this new guy was staring
at me not making eye contact with the
other man actually he wasn't just
staring at me
he was eyeing my body up and down
I felt exposed and uncomfortable but
let's face it it wasn't the first guy
that couldn't keep his eyes off me it's
just that usually they try a little bit
to hide it he continued to fire off
questions I couldn't understand I looked
up at the rain forest we'd been
exploring it wasn't exactly as I
pictured it how far was the zip line
where was the waterfall
that's when both of them went quiet
I looked back down at them both of them
were staring at me
I smiled sheepishly then the two men
simultaneously grabbed me I tried to
scream but one of their hands reached
over and muffled my mouth as both of
them dragged me down to the ground
I was completely helpless to resist with
the full weight of two bodies crushing
me a hand pinched my nose and closed my
nostrils tears began to flow but I
couldn't breathe
I was completely powerless there was
nothing I could do the black started to
envelop me from the corners of my vision
just before I blacked out I saw
something in a blur through my tears
deep in the distance there was a
third-person way back in the trees it
was the last thing I saw before the
black crashed in and I was out for the
second time that day I awoke in a haze I
thought I never would but I was alive it
was getting dark out but we were still
in the forest a different part of the
forest I didn't know how deep and we
were I actually couldn't make out much
my vision was a blur it was like looking
through beer goggles my right arm felt
dead almost impossible to lift but with
some effort I could move it around and
shoe off some of the hundreds of bugs
flying right over my body it didn't do
much good they were everywhere
the two men were sitting by a campfire
talking clearly they hadn't noticed me
wake up from what I could tell they were
about 10 meters away there was also a
jeep parked nearby - I felt as if I was
hung over and drunk at the same time but
this was my only chance to try to escape
and I knew it there were just a few
problems I had no idea where I was how
far we were from the beach or from any
civilization for that matter
I was not in much condition to run I
still had no shoes and my bikini was not
great for running in to begin with
normally I might be more confident I do
jog for 45 minutes almost every day so I
had pretty good endurance I didn't know
what these two men were capable of
though and then there was that third guy
I had seen in the distance where was he
was he one of them was he going to be
patrolling the perimeter before I could
think of a plan
I saw them turn their back to me and go
to the car this was my chance i wobble
to my feet I didn't break into a full
sprint right away trying to strike a
balance between speed and stealth as I
got further from the campfire it got
very dark even just a few meters ahead
of me was starting to look pitch-black
it wasn't long before I stepped on
something hard and rough it rolled me
off my feet and I went crashing to the
ground shoot I heard their yelling out
in the distance as they realized I was
gone I pulled myself to by feet feeling
even woozy er than before I heard the
Jeep start somewhere in the background
the headlights flared up behind me
so I scrambled my way up the nearest
bump in the terrain and ducked out
behind it doing my best not to
a muscle the area lit up as the vehicle
turned around and headed in my direction
it pretty much mowed over the low-lying
vegetation as a tor over the bumpy
terrain and headed straight for me
they didn't see me the Jeep passed and I
was safe for a little while longer
I figured I'd have to develop a strategy
so I could continue in one direction as
to not send myself in circles I decided
to go perpendicular to the way they had
just driven that way if they tried to
comb the area it will take them a long
time to get to me I got to my feet and
set off but then I heard something that
stopped me in my tracks
it wasn't loud I wasn't even entirely
sure I had heard it at all until I heard
it again there were footsteps probably a
good 30 meters or so my head was still
spinning and I couldn't exactly tell
which direction they were coming from
once again I had to reassess my
situation I looked around absolutely no
light
other than the faint moon's glow I
couldn't make out where the footsteps
were coming from or who they were coming
from what if only one of them had gotten
in the car or could this be that third
person I had seen in the distance it
could be a random person for all I knew
it might be worth calling out for help
but if it was one of them I didn't have
time to sit and think about it the
footsteps were getting louder I decided
to try and quietly move away it was
getting harder to get around though not
only was it dark but my vision was
swirling more and more it seemed like
the more ground I covered the louder the
other footsteps got the anxiety the
swirling headache the sick feeling I had
all of it was getting to me before I
knew what had happened
I collapsed I laid on the ground
breathing heavily the last thing I saw
this time was a pair of boots on the
ground in front of me they walked up and
stopped just before my face I couldn't
go on I felt myself start to fade once
again number 13 international waters
Bali come on they're leaving
I called back my wife as she waddled
down the dock and her high heels what's
the point I thought to myself we were
going to miss it it was already three
minutes past two the boat should have
left by now sure enough just as we got
to the end of the dock the ship pulled
away and headed out to sea if only she
hadn't taken so long to get ready
oh no she sorry Tom I just missed it too
come on we can still enjoy the poolside
bar for a few more hours while the sun's
still up I turned back towards the
mainland then I heard a voice behind me
it came from one of the island locals
who was sitting at the end of the pier
apparently there was going to be a
smaller shuttle boat that would take
people out to the casino in about an
hour
perfect for us I made sure next time we
were waiting out there 15 minutes early
right at 3:00 p.m. the same guy from the
dock earlier pulled up at a tiny speed
boat he helped us aboard then once we
were seated he fired up the engine I
asked him if we were going to have to
wait for any other guests he told us we
were the only ones so just like that
we tuck off the sea breeze withdraw her
hair as the island behind us got smaller
and smaller in the distance
Molly grabbed onto me for safety as we
looked into the sparkling horizon
eventually a speck appeared on that
horizon now long after that the speck
became a boat the boat upon which we'd
be spending the rest of our Eve when we
walked in the place was popping
blackjack tables poker roulette a disco
ball bumping to the beat of the bass and
bottle girls her every table couch and
chair it looked like there were more in
the rooms beyond as well we probably
spent the first four hours in this
initial room
I wasn't really keeping track of time
but that was more of an estimate based
on the amount of drinks me and my wife
had down we jumped around from the game
decayed spending some time together and
some apart I wanted to give one more
spin at the roulette table and I wasn't
sure where exactly she had right off to
I was getting kind of low on chips and I
wondered if she was doing any better
I noticed the guy next to me had a huge
stack of chips the most I had seen
anyone with the entire night I inquired
about where he had all the good luck and
he told me he made almost all of his
earnings in the private rooms he went on
to explain that the casino operates
offshore because what goes on in the
private rooms is very illegal but not in
international waters I asked if he had
any tips he told me to stay calm be
logical and don't do anything rash he
said you can make a lot of money there
but you have to know when it's a good
time to sit back and observe and when
it's a good time to punch and buy and hi
and the last thing he told me was that
that room was now for the light-hearted
or the morally righteous I went to go
find mom
the first area beyond the curtain door
was a little waiting area with a bouncer
he asked us if we wanted to play in a
private room and made sure that we knew
we had to stay for the duration of the
game so if we had to use the restroom to
do it now he reiterated but the one guy
told me about this being a moral ground
zero then we waited I hadn't noticed
anyone come out of the room but after we
waited for about 20 minutes the door
opened and we found two chairs in front
of a bank teller window type of thing
with a little slot presumably to
exchange our chips beyond the window was
a bigger room with several vertical wall
panels made up of great metal sheets
there was a door in the corner of the
room and a large mirror on each wall a
bright disc shaped light on the ceiling
was the only means of illumination
someone stepped into the room with us it
was one of their bottle girls she poured
each of us a glass and explained that
tonight's game would come in three parts
minimum that would be 15 credits and we
would be required to place a bet for
each game the first game would require
us to bet on who would hang in the
longest suddenly I felt a bit of a nasty
feeling as I thought about all the
warnings of moral values when it was
described to me I imagined something
along the lines of the board came sorry
or he had to bump off the other players
to win
I hadn't even anticipated the
possibility of a survival game so you
can imagine my relief when they will
five horizontal bars into the room
beyond our window I guess my wife had
gotten the same idea when they said who
can hang in the longest what came to
your mind haha I guess I thought we were
sponsoring the Hunger Games for a second
there that's when they marched five
women completely naked out onto the
floor
my wife cleared at me I told her I
honestly had no idea but she crossed her
arms each of the woman took their place
under the bars my immediate thought was
that when I first saw them they'd look
tired and disheveled they certainly
didn't seem happy to be there but given
what I thought the circumstances were a
minute ago it didn't bother me as much
as it should have so we just have to
pick two which one can hang on the bar
the longest seems easy the lightest one
should have the advantage second from
the right yeah but what about grip
strength how would we know what their
grip strength is like I don't know maybe
the one on the left maybe the one next
to her this feels so wrong it's like
we're slave traders up here or something
I could tell that she was half joking
but a small part of me did feel it was
wrong
sitting up here judging these exposed
women based on their bodies our drinks
were refilled and we were given a little
card without going into too much detail
the card contained odds and buying price
for each Kennedy our skinny candidate
had the best odds but that also meant
she had the biggest buy-in price so the
system they had here was kind of an
inverse from what you would expect from
a horse truck or something similar
we still decided to go for the small
chick anyways I could feel the drink
starting to get to me as I counted out
how many chips I need to put in a bet on
her
once the bets were in one more of the
casino employees went down into the room
and dumped a bucket of water onto the
floor the water spread evenly throughout
the room creating a shallow pool all the
way around what is that for
I don't know maybe it's to make it
obvious if someone touches the ground to
be honest I really had no idea but soon
I would find out the competition began
and all five ladies jumped onto the bar
one of them immediately lost her handle
and came crashing to the ground her
scream was cut short by an electric buzz
she was flailing and freaking out on the
ground that's when I realized the true
intent of the ground water it wasn't to
show Who I touched look round I mean
maybe it was but the main purpose was a
motivation to stay on the bar there was
some kind of an electric current running
through the water probably not enough to
kill but definitely enough to pack a
punch the poor lady was screeching and
desperately trying to get back to the
bar but she didn't have what it takes to
hold on
she kept fun and getting shocked then
trying to pull herself back up before
falling again it was hard to watch after
about 20 seconds the girl next to her
went down and it looked like the search
that went through her was even more
violence she however was able to get
back up on to the bar and wrap her legs
around it in order to avoid further pain
the first woman just wasn't able to pull
herself up though molly was having
difficulty stomaching what she was
seeing she grabbed my hand and gave me a
helpless look of concerned let's get out
of here we headed for the exit but the
door was locked
hey we're done let us out but we were
reminded that we had agreed to stay for
the entire game and I realized that not
only would we have to sit there but we'd
also have to place bets and continue to
support the degrading inhumane
experiences that were going on down
there what had I gotten us into another
girl fell and got a short jolt of
electricity before hopping and wrapping
her legs around the bar for safety it
came down to two final girls our girl
and the more muscular looking girl I'd
suggested earlier
our goal started to lose her grip and
shifted around to regain her position
but a couple of seconds later she was
wobbling again she cried out and
actually burst into tears while still
holding onto the bar
I guess she already knew she was going
to lose but continued to hold on for as
long as possible
before long she slept and I could
actually hear her yell out as she did
luckily she only had a few seconds of
voltage the current seemed to shut off
and the last woman led herself down from
the barn safety the whole thing was
maybe a minute and a half but the first
to have fallen was in pain for all of
that she was alive but she didn't get up
right away
her hair was literally standing up in
all directions and her skin was charred
like something out of a cartoon it was
just disgusting to watch our barrack but
that's probably not a strong enough word
to describe the pain she must have been
in eventually the room was cleared and a
water vacuum was used to dry things up
as the bars were taken out in
preparation of the next game they ended
up bringing out these big white yellow
rulers about four feet in length and
placing them against the wall when they
brought the women back out they had on
nothing but these knee-high boots which
subsequently latched into the wall at
the knee and at the toe so their shins
were pretty much locked in parallel to
the wall our drinks were refilled we
were given another card simply labeled
flexibility like before it gave us odds
and a buy-in price for each contestant I
noticed that some of them were the same
but if he had been swapped out the final
two girls from the last game were still
in there we again come to plated not
betting we stalled for a few minutes
hoping they would just start the game
without our bed the bottle goal came
back and told us there had been a change
and exchanged the card we had for
another card the only difference was
they added one more contestant again we
tried to wait it out without betting but
we were interrupted by a bouncer who
burst into the room and told us that we
had to hurry up and make up
we tried to explain that we were no
longer comfortable with it but it did
not help
I realized our best option was just to
finish the game and not come back we
soon realized there were only two
contestants out of the six that we can
even afford with the chips we had left
they were the bottom two in terms of
odds we went with the cheapest one
wanting to support this heinous game as
little as possible the game started and
the object was to been as far back as
possible in a bridge position the score
was measured by how close they could get
their hands to their heels
it didn't seem like this game would be
nearly as brutal as the last one but I
was unfortunately surprised how close it
came I saw contortions I didn't even
think we're possible
all the contestants were able to see
each other and each of them seemed to be
trying their hardest if there was some
kind of external motivator in this game
like there was in the last one I
couldn't see what it was but I could
tell none of them wanted to lose it got
to the point that one of the girls was
pushing herself so hard that she
screamed out and collapsed onto the
floor and she wasn't able to go any
further as they continued to strain
there were two clear leaders the petite
girl on the more buff looking one who
were the final two in the previous round
this time a smaller girl came out on top
and her rival slammed her hand on the
floor in frustration
round two was over only one to go the
ladies were pushed to the breaking point
but I was just glad we got through that
one with no one's back being broken it
wasn't even the worst thing in the world
I was hoping that the final round would
be more tame and we could get out of
there with somewhat of a lighter
conscience hopefully we'd be able to
suppress this night and enjoy the rest
of our vacation after this that all went
out the window with what happened next
though five men came into the room each
carrying a long-nosed rifle gun but
before you asked
no no one was shot during the game but I
didn't know that at the time that's not
to say what actually ended up going down
wasn't horrifying though the barrel of
each of these guns was painted with a
series of rainbow color stripes
stretching from the tip of the gun
inwards
I didn't understand what the meaning
this was until the bottle girl came out
and gave us the final card printed upon
it was the name of the last game an
iteration it looked at it in this belief
but before I could even begin to protest
Molly pointed out that with the chips we
had left we couldn't even afford the
cheapest buy-in maybe this would
probably prompt them in kicking us out
we were more than ready to be done with
this place but after we once again
failed to place a bet the bouncer came
in to see what was up we explained our
situation and he told us we'd have to
get more chips and told my wife to come
with them minutes later he came back
with a velvet bag and handed it it was
filled with tons of chips way more than
what we ever had more than the guide to
roulette table or than we could ever
probably afford where's my wife I asked
but he was already gone that's when the
bottle girl came through one more time
with another card and Hanan told me that
there's been a change I turned around
and looked into the window into the game
room and what I saw was more upsetting
and disturbing than anything I had laid
eyes upon that evening stripped down and
shaking with fear Molly had joined the
lineup of contestants
number fourteen isolated getaway this
isn't easy for me to talk about if
you've ever tried to make long-term
plans in a relationship you'll probably
know what it's like my boyfriend and I
had gone out for two years and decided
to plan a relaxing little getaway
he never think that this kind of thing
would happen when you're planning our
trip but we ended up splitting up a
month and a half before ideally I would
have waited until after the vacation to
break up with him but when I caught him
fooling around with his physical
therapist I didn't even wait a day
before ending it
luckily for me I still had a suite
booked at the Grand Maritime Beach
Resort for whatever reason even though
he did all the research and booking the
reservation was made under both of our
names with my email address I figured it
would be a good consolation prize for
the suffering he put me through besides
I wasn't going to let him ruin my
much-needed time off he'd already done
enough damage I'd be enjoying this
vacation with or without him it felt
amazing to hop off the plane and stuff
my winter jacket into my back the rest
of the week I breezed through the
airport at the end of which a short
chubby guy asked me if I needed a ride I
told him that I was looking for the
grand maritime shuttle and it turned out
that he was the driver I guess I logged
out because we didn't even have to wait
for other passengers I'd be enjoying
that sunshine before I knew it once we
arrived at the resort they told me my
room wasn't quite ready but they offered
to take my bags and let me enjoy the
pool and beach while they made the
preparations to be honest that's exactly
what I wanted I would worry about
unpacking later I got changed in the
bathroom and found myself a poolside
chair the resort was not at all when I
remembered my ex describing to me
first I expected more people I mean I
was the only one at the pool area it
looked like there was some more people
by the beach but it felt like it should
have been much more busy at this time of
year still I didn't mind some isolation
and time to myself
it was also kind of a shoddy place I
remember it looking much better in the
photos leave it to my stupid ex to not
do the research who cares though I was
here catching some Sun and not at work
a couple of loose pool tiles wouldn't
change that I decided to take a look
around the resort a bit again
I was pretty unimpressed actually it was
kind of creepy I felt as though it
hadn't been renovated since the 70s
and there was nobody around it was like
exploring the ruins of a forgotten old
resort there was a smaller pool that I
came across that was empty and filled
with moss the paintings on the wall were
cute or at least they might have been
several years ago but the paint had
chipped away so that the eyes of the
tribal figures were depicted just as
empty voids I felt more like I was in a
forbidden temple than a welcoming beach
resort corroded statues and broken
fences were just a couple more clues as
to why the place was so empty there was
even a boat on the beach that was turned
over in the sand gutted for parts and
covered in graffiti perhaps the
strangest part about it were the tiny
little speakers hidden in rocks around
the resort which were probably the only
evidence that the place was actually
operational I decided to just go back to
the pool in ten until my room was ready
while I waited one of the staff came up
to me and asked if I was interested in a
complimentary massage that sounded good
to me I followed him into a spa building
next to the pool I laid out facedown on
the massage table and he began to go to
work on my shoulders it was oddly quiet
no music or anything just the sound of
him breathing and kneading my flesh it
was a bit uncomfortable but at the same
time it felt so good so I tried to
ignore it then it got more uncomfortable
the guy just presumably unhooks my
bikini and goes to work on the part of
my back insides I don't usually get a
lot of massages but shouldn't he ask
before doing something like that then I
remembered why I was here and I thought
I should let myself live a little
someone else came into the room and
started talking to the masseuse in a
language I couldn't understand it
sounded like he was answering a bunch of
questions and he sounded kind of angry
his voice got louder as he came into the
room it sounded like he was right next
to my head so I opened my eyes and the
guy was right there staring at me
I panicked but I didn't quite know what
to do he started pacing around the room
talking to the guy I felt like his eyes
were locked on to me my relaxation level
dropped fast and my nervousness level
was skyrocketing this guy was
unbelievable
but then he actually grabs my butt I
screamed out hey but I couldn't fully
turn away without exposing myself I was
just about ready to be done with this
massage why wasn't the masseuse telling
this creep to buzz off the guy didn't
let me go when I yelled at him what the
hell they just carried on their
conversation only raising their voices
so I started kicking and thrashing my
feet and screaming at them to stop the
only problem was I could raise all the
ruckus I wanted but we all knew that
there was probably nobody out there to
hear me I tried to fight my way out but
the masseuse ended my struggle swiftly
when he dug his thumbs somewhere into my
shoulders as hard as he could
he must have hit some pressure point or
something because that was the last
thing I remembered I was out I woke up
by the time I remembered what had
happened I realized that I was in a far
worse situation I was on a speedboat
sipping through the ocean accompanied by
only that strange man who had violated
me I could see the island off in the
distance and it was only getting further
and further away I jumped out of the
boat as swear as fast as I possibly
could I heard the engine
and the driver turned around as soon as
he realized that was gone before I knew
it the boat was back in front of me he
told me it was stupid to try to swim
back and that it was further than it
looked and yanked me back into the boat
he was right I didn't have the stamina
to swim all the way back to shore as I
stared off at how far it really was
I saw a resort on the coast that looked
far nicer than my own why couldn't my
stupid ex have done his research and
book that decent place that's when I
realized something the sign displayed
above the resort just barely read in the
distance
it said grand maritime Beach Resort
number 15 last resort I looked up and
saw a ship departing from the dock a
couple of jet ski riders zoomed by the
ships away even managing and catch a
little air that looked fun maybe I could
do a little bit of that later I dug my
toes into the warm sand and looked at my
watch it was 203 it seemed like as good
a time as any to grab myself a drink
after all the bar here the grand
maritime was complimentary so why not
Lucy Lucy you okay I shipped my sleeping
girlfriend shoulder lightly to see if
she wanted anything oh yeah I just fell
asleep
what time is it about soon you were
tired
you look dead Thanks I was just going up
to the bar do you want anything to drink
you could grab me a pina colada I guess
okay with that I kissed her and headed
off to the bar when I got back with the
drinks my girlfriend seemed to have
wandered off so I resumed my position on
the lounge chair and stared off at the
shoreline for a bit full of hope that
this was gonna be the best a vacation
ever
this was so nice about 15 minutes went
by Lucy still didn't show up ten minutes
more in another 15 minutes where had she
run off to
there was this old German couple of the
chairs behind us I asked if they'd seen
a blonde girl in a black bikini sitting
here and where she might have headed off
to they said they had seen her talking
to the survey guy when I asked who the
survey guy was they told me he was going
around from chair to chair with a
clipboard asking people if they'd like
to fill out a 15 minute satisfaction
survey and that they'd seen him talking
to Lucy I asked what direction that gone
but neither one of them was sure
immediately I knew something was wrong
Lucy was not the type to spend 15
minutes filling out a survey especially
on vacation the next closest person was
an attractive young girl sipping on a
smoothie by herself I asked her if she
might have seen my girlfriend possibly
with a guy holding a clipboard she told
me she wasn't sure about Lucy but she
may have seen the clipboard guy
according to her he had been going from
chair to chair and had asked her if she
wanted to sign up for some kind of
island adventure thing but she had
politely declined apparently he was
really pushing it but she just wasn't
interested we were interrupted by a guy
who was about my age wearing long swim
trunks excuse me my apologies for
interrupting I just happened to overhear
that you say that you were looking for
your girlfriend my wife seems to have
disappeared off this beach earlier this
morning when I ran back to the room to
get some sunscreen I've been looking all
over and haven't been able to find her
yeah I just once at the bar and came
back she was gone
it's been almost an hour so I started
asking around why don't we both
investigate knowing my wife there's
probably some spa we don't know about
that they've both run off to yeah you're
probably right let's go find him the
girl I was talking to said the guy with
the clipboard was headed down the beach
to the left so we continued that way my
name's Mike by the way Gary we continued
asking around one guy said that he'd
seen the survey guy come by but he told
him he wasn't interested
another couple said they hadn't seen
either of them
then one shaykh said that some guy had
asked her to come down to the activity
Shack to sign up for some kind of
rainforest adventure and she'd said no
that's when I remembered lucy and i
checking into the hotel she found this
pamphlet with all of these activities I
think she told me she was interested in
doing some rainforest hike or something
Mike and I decided to look for this
activity Shack we headed down the beach
to the end of the resort's property well
Mike I guess this is where we turn back
I say we continue searching down the
beach for this supposed activity Shack
I've already searched every inch of the
resort for my wife I'm convinced they're
off property somewhere I guess I walked
down a bit further with you I've got
nothing to lose by checking we continue
down the beach until we found an empty
Shack it didn't look like an activity
Shack per se just more of a little Hut
before moving on
Mike noticed something in the sand he
pulled up and dust it off of cliff board
there was one page on an empty
spreadsheet with the words resort survey
crudely printed at the top we looked at
each other
Mike was wide-eyed he flipped over the
paper the back was completely different
a coloured advertisement with bright
graphics of ziplining a campfire and a
waterfall something here didn't add up I
only saw two pairs of footsteps in the
sand heading back out of the activity
Shack instead of leading back to the
resort they led back inland toward a
street something is not right here Mike
and I headed to the street where some
sand was kicked up onto the pavement
someone had definitely jaywalked right
here and so we headed across the street
into a rainforest we decided to spread
out a little bit and cover as much
ground as possible we made sure to stay
within an earshot of each other so when
we inevitably got lost at least we
weren't separated from each other
Lucy Lucy it seemed like we were totally
alone in this forest
it seemed useless I was about ready to
turn and go back they couldn't be out
here but that's when I heard Mike call
out to me Gary over here come quick my
heart joltin and I ran over him I was
looking around over here and I saw
something way off in the distance
there were three figures standing there
two men and a woman I was about to call
out to them when the two men jumped the
lady and knocked her out when they
noticed me staring they carried her into
a car and sped off I think it could have
been your girlfriend I felt a sharp pain
of nervousness and excitement in my
chest could it have been Lucy I wanted
to be close to finding her but I
couldn't stand the idea of her not being
okay we ran over there there was no real
evidence to speak of but there were tire
tracks that we could follow not only was
it our best bet of finding our women but
it was probably our only bet for finding
our way out of here
we ended up following these tracks for
three full hours it was getting dark by
the time we came across a little
campsite there was a bonfire that had
recently been put out the wood was still
charred and I could smell smoke the
tracks continued on from there though
and thirty minutes later we were finally
led out of the forest where the tire
marks continued on sand it was a private
little beach area hidden by rocks and
both sides we eventually reached the end
of the tracks where a Jeep was parked in
the sand near the water and some
footsteps led right into the ocean
itself shoot we wouldn't be able to
track them through the water and there
were so many different ways they could
have gone my heart ached as the hope
inside of me began to die I stared into
the same crystal blue waters that I had
just hours before but now with an
outlook of despair I felt like I was
never gonna see her again I looked over
to Mike I have an idea
I'd never ridden a jet ski before but I
was gonna have to learn quick it was
easy enough to get the hang of and I
soon found myself focusing more on
looking for the boat than worrying about
the controls we were back in front of
the grand maritime resort now there was
a little speedboat whipping across the
currents in the distance a woman sat up
and jumped off of the boat she was
thrashing in the water swimming back
towards the coast the driver of the boat
turned back and pulled her back in did
you see that
and that was weird let's keep an eye on
them so we did our best to follow this
boat making sure not to get too close or
to follow him too directly at any point
we Zig zagged our way around just
staying barely within an eye shot
eventually the boat pulled in next to a
much larger ship which was anchored out
at sea the guy tied a rope tethering him
to the larger ship then climbed aboard
dragging the woman with him you Parker
was up next in the speedboat ohad mind
along the other side of the ship and
swim back around to the side that way if
they see yours we'll have a backup to
escape on and this was this if we didn't
find Lucy here and I was probably never
gonna see her again I parked the jet ski
and climbed onto the boat we headed down
a dark metal hallway trying to keep our
footsteps as quiet as possible as we
traveled down the sound of music
thumping from another room got louder
some kind of party was going on on the
other side of this wall there was a door
on the side or we could just continue
further down the hall into the dark I
decided to peek inside of the door and
opened it just a crack it was a huge
room dark with vibrant neon lights tons
of people dressed up sat at slot
machines and blackjack tables I quickly
and quietly closed the door hoping I
hadn't been noticed I nodded my head at
Mike to continue further down the
corridor which we couldn't see the end
of because of the dark Mike put his hand
out in front of me to stop he motioned
to his ear and I listened I could hear
breathing at the end of the hallway
there was no doubt that someone was
standing guard we knew he was there and
he knew we were here then as if to break
the silence and tension his voice called
out in the dark and told us we weren't
allowed back here and to head back into
the casino Mike whispered for me to keep
quiet then spoke out to the guy excuse
me sir I was just looking for my wife I
believe she may had wandered back this
way the guard told him that nobody had
been through this way but Mike insisted
he double check we heard the door he was
guarding creak open and Mike dragged me
forward into the dark to where we could
see the end of the hall he yanked on the
door but it had automatically locked so
he hid in the corner behind the door
stand I'm white van to come through I
could see where Mike was going with this
I wasn't convinced it would work but I
couldn't come up with much better the
guard came back through the door and saw
me standing in the hall I said nothing
he told me that nobody had gotten back
there thanks the voice came from behind
him as Mike jumped on the guy's back
taking him by surprise before he had a
chance to close the door behind him I
bolted through the door and made it it's
shut with a huge metallic Clank I would
be on my own from here on out the room I
found myself in was some kind of lab
there were several rows of operation
tables and these vertical tubes with a
blue glow emanating from them I
inspected the first one it seemed to
just be an empty water tank though it
did contain what looked like kind of a
scuba regulator at the end of a tube
before I could inspect any further I
heard a door being unlocked and I
quickly doh behind the tank to find
please I just want to get my husband and
go back to my hotel hey what do you
think you're doing your hands off me two
men who look to be employees of the
casino slammed this woman to the
operating table with her screaming all
the while I couldn't see fully what they
were doing the hurt from where I was but
I did see the man's pants drop at his
ankles and based on the screams I'm sure
you can guess the rest
it was hard enough to stand by and let
this happen but I also kept imagining my
Lucy in the same situation my fists were
shaking with rage
I was gritting my teeth and I could
barely contain myself
still I had the advantage of them not
knowing I was here and if I was gonna
have any chance I had to keep it that
way the girl on the table seemed to just
give up the fight and the man doing the
thrusting said 10 to 1 then spewed out a
bunch of different numbers as if he was
some kind of twisted odds maker then the
girl now stark naked was pushed out into
another room then the guy followed her
out there with a rifle gun whoa I was in
way over my head I had no way to defend
myself against that I had to find Lucy
and get out of there without getting
caught the first guy went into a
different door and it looked like he
headed up some stairs I jumped up to
investigate the rest of the lab there
were more of these water tanks
stretching down the length of the room
what I found was that many of them
contained women again completely exposed
breathing through tubes I had recognized
one of them as the lady we'd seen jump
off the speedboat earlier the next girl
looked in much worse shape her skin
looked charred and her hair was standing
up in every direction my hope was
dwindling but what happened next I I
can't even explain the feeling that shot
through me it was Lucy I nearly blacked
out upon seeing her I was feeling every
emotion a person can feel all at once
her eyes were closed and she was just
gracefully floating there breathing
through him ask but definitely breathing
I knocked on the glass unsure of how to
get her out she didn't hear I knocked
harder and her I shot open you could
just see that they were immediately
filled with fear that she'd been
conditioned to expect abuse but once she
recognized me everything changed she put
her hand up to the glass and I reached
up and did the same once again I heard
the door unlocked and
ducked in the hiding this time it was
two men one looked like it native to the
island the other was a foreigner both
were wearing suits the foreign guy had a
drink in his hand he was overweight and
seemed to have a breathing problem there
was a metal tube coming out of his neck
that seemed to be regulating his
respiratory system to understand the
relevance of games 2 & 3
[Music]
what was the point of the first game the
Islander guy responded simply to break
them this one performed a fine specimen
indeed they started talking prices and
times that was it I couldn't stand by
anymore and watch this freaking guy
[ __ ] out my girlfriend I didn't care if
I got myself killed I couldn't sit there
and hide anymore I crawled out the guy
didn't see me
I got a running start and knocked the
[ __ ] in the face full-speed I shattered
my fist but I didn't even realize it at
the time before he knew I hit him I
grabbed the fat by the back of the neck
and thrashed his face into the glass it
didn't budge but it must have set off
some kind of alarm and a red light
started flashing and thrust his face
into the glass two three four times
before it started to show a crack which
I noticed on the rowing splash of liquid
red now on the surface of the window I
reared back one more time with all my
might and shattered the tank on this
guy's skull water washed out everywhere
with a greater force than I had expected
Lucy went sliding across the lab floor
it helped her get to her feet but there
was no time for a heartfelt reunion we
ran for our lives as we exited I heard
the voices of yelling men behind us we
made it to the hall where I had left my
in the guard I wasn't sure where the
guard had gone but it was clear what had
happened to Mike he was beaten to a pulp
and left sprawled on the floor there was
no time to mourn if we were lucky we
might just get out alive we made it to
the hatch somehow I was able to pry it
open we were back into the open air
almost home-free
but what waited on the other side would
be possibly my toughest challenge yet
the guard who had beaten up Mike was
standing over the jet ski I had pulled
up in which was on fire and he continued
to pour on the gasoline he turned around
in socks not knowing what else to do I
pushed him hoping to catch him off
balance or something and somehow it
worked
he went crashing down into the flaming
vehicle before falling into the water I
had no idea if he'd gotten to the other
jetski but it was our only hope this way
I took my girlfriend's hand and jumped
out into the ocean we swam like there is
no tomorrow where are we going
the ship billowed its horn over and over
I began to fear it might be a distress
call
still if we got to the jetski that
probably wasn't much they could do to
catch us this was it it all came down to
the escape we turned the corner around
the outside of the ship to where Mike's
jet ski should have been but it was gone
so that's it then it was all for nothing
there what's that over there off in the
distance was Mike's jet ski it had just
drifted away from the ship there was a
long swim but we made it the rest of the
night was mostly a blur I don't remember
much of when we crashed into the shore
terrifying the tourists who are enjoying
the ocean and moonlight I don't remember
the trip to the emergency room but I do
remember when the pain of what they had
done to me finally set in the police
came to talk to us as did some
representatives from the resort the
casino was in international waters so it
was out of the jurisdiction of the law
but they told us they were doing
everything they could do to stop
abductions on the land and keep tourists
informed on the dangers of gambling
offshore they had warnings posted all
over the island but that didn't stop
people from being drawn to the thrill
and they would find other ways to lure
people in the resort wasn't involved in
any of this but of course they told us
they would be striving to improve their
security on the beach and make sure
people knew what dangers lie beyond
their walls they were kind enough to pay
our medical bill and we wouldn't have to
worry about paying for our stay either
they even offered a free week at the
resort at a time of our choosing but I
already knew we would never be coming
back the pain of my broken hand was
really starting to set in the police
wanted to know more about Mike and his
wife but we didn't have much information
to help them other than the fact that
his wife was still out there
I asked if trafficking had always been a
problem on this island
his response made everything that had
happened that night seemed even scarier
he scoffed at me and said if only it was
just trafficking bonus video unboxing my
silver play button welcome to a little
break in the creepypasta action I've got
a little bonus video for you guys as
promised so for this I'm gonna be
unboxing my silver play button that I
got for getting 100,000 subscribers on
YouTube at least that's what I hope this
is because it does have the YouTube
sticker and it did come to me in the
mail hopefully it's not just like a
water bottle or something
so I'm actually kind of interested to
see what this is going to be because
they recently changed the design of
their play buttons
oh very nice very nice packaging from
YouTube I'm going to toss this box out
of the way I also removed any stickers
from that that might docks me but yeah
they changed the the look of the play
buttons so I don't actually know if I'm
gonna have the new one or the old one
because they changed it pretty soon
after I ordered my button very nice
packaging YouTube it would be kind of
cool if I had the old one because then I
would be one of the few creators who
gets their silver play button as the old
one and their gold play button is the
new one from YouTube you've just done
something that very few YouTube creators
accomplished you had an astonishing
100,000 people subscribe to your channel
we know that numbers on YouTube can get
really big but we hope you don't lose
sight of the reality behind that six
digit milestone each and every person
who is subscribed to your channel has
been touched by what you've created they
were inspired challenged or entertained
well I hope I hope if you're watching
this then you have been moved by what I
created you achieve this milestone with
hard work perseverance and probably a
healthy sense of humor too you can be
the judge of that
what what you've accomplished can't be
taken away from you and we'd like to
recognize you and all your hard work
with this silver creator award a small
token of
our esteem and respect we know that you
don't do this for rewards you do it
because you have a drive to create and
share because you found an audience who
cares believe us when we say that we
can't wait to see what you do next a
million subscribers may be a long way
off now but you're closer than you think
and we're rooting for you
sincerely Susan Wojcicki signed the this
paper all right enough of this this what
you really want to see is the silver
creator award and it does look like it's
the old one so very cool take the
packaging off of this thing
congratulations C Z's world I'm passing
100,000 subscribers I'll have to figure
out where I'm gonna put this but anyway
just a quick little break from the
creepypasta narration and let's get
right back that's big right back in with
the next story
number 16 forbidden house this is a
story that happened several years back
when trick-or-treating with my friend
Alex
my older brother Jon and his friend Evan
every neighborhood has that one house
that nobody ever wants to trick-or-treat
at whether it be because of bad candy
mean owners a dentist house fear or
otherwise in this case our parents had
told us that we could go off on our own
this year as long as we stayed together
and agreed not to go to that house I was
in fourth grade that year and the idea
of getting to go off on our own was
exciting to me at the time
so naturally I agreed when Alex and Evan
got to our house we waited around and
answered the door for a while trying to
scare some of the younger
trick-or-treaters eventually after our
parents took our baby sister to some of
the houses we grabbed her pillowcases
and set off to get some candy we lived
in a pretty safe neighborhood so it was
common for kids our age or even younger
to go out alone looking back now I had
grown up in a borderline pretentious
suburban neighborhood the type of
community you'd see in movies like
Donnie Darko or American Beauty almost
everyone in our neighborhood had
decorations and those who didn't had
these decorative wooden ghosts nailed to
the side of their mailbox they were more
of a cutesy decoration than scary but
they did give a nice uniformity to all
the houses in the neighborhood it was
starting to get dark when we reached the
house that our parents told us not to go
to this wasn't your stereotypical dark
manner at the end of the block but it
was a little further away from the
street than many of the other houses and
sort of tucked back behind some trees I
suggested that we go back to our house
to dump whatever candy we had off before
hitting up another neighborhood but John
and the others were curious to see what
the big deal was about the dark house
I'll have to admit I was quite curious
about why my parents didn't want us
going over there
and it did seem harmless enough so I
figured they would have no way of
knowing if we quickly hit this house the
driveway was long and dark and there was
no light coming from the house
whatsoever this was one of those houses
where the front door was more on the
side of the house with a curved path
leading back up to the front I noticed
that this house did not have the wood
Ghost attached to the mailbox like every
other house in the neighborhood and as
we walked up I was starting to get a
little nervous and I told John that I
didn't think anyone was home but he
thought I was just trying to chicken out
and continue down anyways we reached the
house and John loudly banged on the door
it was taking forever and I was fairly
convinced that the guy wasn't home or
didn't want to deal with
trick-or-treaters just when I was ready
to turn and give up on the house we all
fell silent as the sound of footsteps
could be heard on the other side of the
door while this did make me nervous
I was also excited to see what was on
the other side of the door that made my
parents so worried about this house so I
stepped back a little bit giving myself
some room to run if maybe the door open
revealing an older man with a cane this
immediately alleviated some of my
anxiety as it would be pretty easy to
run if need be the man was actually very
nice and told us that we were the first
visitors of the night and that he didn't
expect to see many trick-or-treaters
this year
apparently he lived alone and had had
some kind of dispute with the
neighborhood homeowners association over
the upkeep of his property so many of
the adults were trying to get back at
him by excluding him from all the
neighborhood festivities he seemed like
such a nice guy and we actually felt
pretty bad for him we all wished him a
happy Halloween before going on our way
I had felt silly about being nervous
about visiting this house at least
that's how I felt before what happened
next
as we walk down the path back to the
street side of the house I happened to
glance at the upstairs window and saw a
man in a black hood peeking out from
behind the window frame
as soon as I made eye contact with him
he moved back out of sight my stomach
immediately dropped as the man had just
said that he lived alone I bolted as I
told the guys to run but John and Evans
seemed convinced that I was just being a
baby I tried to quickly tell them that
there was a man in the window but I
don't think they believed me however
John being the older of the two of us
was supposed to keep an eye on me so
when I made a mad dash back towards our
house he effectively gave chase I knew
in the back of my mind that although the
old man may not have been mobile that
this other guy was most likely a fully
capable adult who probably would be able
to catch us so I didn't stop until I was
inside the door my parents had just
returned from taking my sister out for a
round of the neighborhood and they could
immediately see that there was something
wrong not wanting to get in trouble for
disobeying them I lied and told them
that we were walking by the house when I
saw a man in black climbing through the
window of the old man's house and that
he had seen us catching him in the act
apparently this was a pretty good cover
story as it was enough to get my mom to
call the cops and four of us locked
inside the house for the rest of the
night the other guys were pretty bummed
out to have her trick-or-treating cut
short and we decided we'd watch a movie
and begin trade negotiations on our
candy a little early this year I had a
hard time paying attention to the movie
and kept looking back to the window
thinking about what the possibility
might be that the guy tracked us here
not much later that night we learned
that the police had searched the old
man's house and found a 19-year old man
hiding in the closet with a knife
apparently the intruder had no idea who
lived there and decided to break in
after seeing the house was completely
dark and being avoided by
trick-or-treaters on Halloween night the
old man was also unharmed but years
later I still shudder to think about
what could have gone down that night
what if I had seen the intruder on the
way up to the house before learning that
the old man lived alone what if the
intruder had been on the first floor and
decided to give chase to us but what
chills me the most is what would have
happened to that nice old man if we had
never trick-or-treated at his house
[Music]
number 17 Secret Santa
for the last couple of years my wife I
have hosted a Secret Santa gift exchange
during the holidays it's a very new
tradition but we thought it would be
nice to put together since a lot of our
friends can't really afford to buy gifts
for everyone we do it a little bit
differently than some people might be
accustomed to everyone randomly gets a
name and has to buy that person and gift
around 50 dollars we have one
get-together where everyone opens their
gifts but even after the swap you never
find out who gave you the gift my wife
and I agreed that that part is important
she says that what makes the holiday
special is having good faith in all of
our friends to get the person something
good in other words if you're only
buying a gift in order to get
recognition for it then the whole idea
is kind of cheapened besides these are
our friends if you can't trust them who
can you trust
sure there are exceptions where it's
obvious who gave the gift like last year
when our friends Emily and Elena who
were married ended up getting each other
or also last year when Cynthia received
a cheap ice tray is her gift from her
recently ex-boyfriend mark we were
optimistic that this year would be
filled with positivity which it was - at
points anyway we have a Secret Santa app
that automatically emails everyone
involved and tells them who they got
it's great because it allows us as the
organizers not to get our Secret Santas
spoiled
I got Troy the newest addition to our
party this year I think I got the
perfect gift for him - every time I go
over to his apartment there's stuff
everywhere plates silverware blu-rays
it's not like he's just too lazy to
clean up after himself it just seems
like he doesn't have anywhere to put it
at all so I got him one of those knife
blocks a dish rack and a silverware
organizer that'll just cover the kitchen
but it's a start I had a feeling Troy
was going to appreciate it
the day of the gift exchange arrived we
had people drop off gifts in a pile as
they came in we all enjoyed some drinks
and snacks as we caught up with each
other for a couple of hours before
getting down to it by the time we
started to open our gifts everyone was
getting a bit giggly my wife pointed out
that Troy seemed to have taken an
interest in her friend Cynthia which we
could both get behind because they were
the only two who were still single it
seemed like the party was alive and well
most of the gifts were really good too
and people kept up their poker faces as
far as I could tell when the present
they brought was being opened of course
there were a couple of obvious moments
like our friend James who most likely
got his own wife seeing as how she
didn't know how anyone else would have
known what she wanted this year
Marco actually ended up getting two
presents somehow I couldn't figure out
why I was worried that the app had
messed up and someone was gonna end up
with no presents but I did a quick count
and realized there were 11 total
presents for the 10 of us I guess
someone just wanted to make Marcos day
and get him something in addition to
buying something through their person he
ended up loving both presents so it
seemed like no harm for the most part
though I just worried it was a bit
unfair to everyone else
the final present remaining came down to
my wife it was a black box wrapped in
what looked to be a plastic trash bag
and tied up in actual rope it was I'm
not gonna lie a really ugly exterior and
she had a lot of trouble opening it by
herself in fact nobody could seem to pry
the knot off of it
granted we were all kind of drunk at
that point so we ended up having to cut
the thing open she opened the box and
pulled out a small piece of paper she
looked upset as she read it then her
hands started to shake and her eyes
glazed over what is it she showed me the
slip of paper there were just a couple
of words on it
Santa says you all die
I quickly looked inside the box only to
find there was nothing else inside I can
get kind of defensive at times and I got
pretty upset and took it out on everyone
within a couple minutes the party was
over and everyone was out in the cold I
wanted to get to the bottom of who the
hell thought this would be funny by
asking everyone who their secret santa
was and doing the little research of my
own to find out who was lying but she
insisted that it wasn't that big of a
deal and she'd rather not ruin it for
everyone still I felt really betrayed
and these were supposed to be our
friends and I couldn't understand who
would want to hurt her like that but we
were tired and just decided to retire to
bed for the evening I told myself I
would get her something great to make up
for it and started brainstorming some
gift ideas but all I could think about
was who would do this I stayed awake for
a while longer trying to think of any
reason that someone would have to try to
spook us that's when I heard someone
rummaging around the house a chill went
up my spine
and after being frozen in fear for a few
moments I sat up and began to formulate
a plan my wife woke up and asked me what
I was doing there's someone in the house
stay here and keep the door locked until
I give you the okay with that I slipped
out and locked the door behind me my
blood was boiling at this point I didn't
know if this had anything to do with the
present from earlier but all I wanted to
do was find who was behind this bash his
head in
the only issue is I couldn't hear anyone
moving around anymore it seemed that the
house was quiet I methodically checked
the entire upstairs
it was empty as I was checking the last
closet I heard a huge crash from
downstairs I sprinted fists blazing but
the scene I found in the living room was
far more horrifying than I could have
imagined the tree had been knocked over
into the fireplace which was now on and
it had begun its burn I heard footsteps
running to the door but I knew I
couldn't go after him now in a panic I
turned off the gas fireplace and ran to
the kitchen to grab a jug of water I
poured it over the tree which was
beginning to burn even more but all I
could manage to do was slow down the
rapidly spreading fire luckily my wife
had already called 9-1-1 and the fire
department showed up before long I was
able to slow down the fire enough until
they arrived I wish I could say that was
the end of it but it gets far worse the
police showed up and questioned us about
what had gone down that evening
we told the entire story and they were
particularly interested in the app we'd
used to sort the names for the Secret
Santa the chief told us that an
undercover police officer would be on
our block for the time being and to call
911 any other disturbances he also gave
me a card a point of contact for if we
had any other information
it was nearly 4:00 a.m. at that point
and we were ready to put this
nightmarish evening behind us when I got
a call from Terry James's wife they were
both at the secrets and of that night
and I noticed a couple of missed calls
from her as well desperate for more
information I picked up but before I
could explain the mess that we had been
in she explained that she was calling
from the hospital apparently they had
been driving home from our house when
some maniac ran them off the road she
was fine but when I'm to explain that
James had been injured pretty badly
though he was expected to make a
recovery I decided that enough was
enough it was time to do a little
investigation of my own the next morning
I headed out to the spot of the crash as
Terry had described to me if I was gonna
get to the bottom of this I had to be
thorough after all as far as I knew
Terry was trying to cover up her James
guilts with that phone
I found tire tracks going off the road
but that really only clears one of them
I made a call on over to the hospital I
knew they wouldn't share any information
since that's someone's private medical
info but I acted like a concerned family
member and asked if they'd been found I
was able to find out they both got
admitted at the same time so they were
both in the clear my next step was
finding out who they got gifts for in
the secret santa which involved me
showing up and asking to see the email I
had to catch them by surprise to make
sure they didn't try to doctor anything
so I knew I had Troy and my wife had a
hemily it was already fairly obvious
that James had his wife Terry but I did
find out that Terry had Elena don't
worry about keeping track of all the
names just know that my list of suspects
was narrowing I also discovered that the
person who went after them was in a
white van
with black tape over the license plate
next on my list were Emily and Elena
it took me a while to come up with an
idea about how I might prove their
whereabouts but I ended up finding a way
to check on them without either of them
knowing see every year there's this big
Christmas tree in town square everyone
in the town is encouraged to put up in
ornaments of their own and the whole
thing is live streamed for the entire
month of December they would most
certainly go past it on their way home
all I had to do was go back to last
night around the time they should have
been driving home luckily enough I was
able to spot their car on the stream
well that didn't necessarily clear both
of them from what happened at our house
it did make them innocent of running
James and Terry off the road unless they
had just gotten a second car that I
don't know about but I figured I could
really ate them if that came to be the
case I also had to make the assumption
that the intruder at our house and the
crazy driver that went after our friends
were related incidents and the time
frame of events seemed to line up with
that theory of course the nasty present
my wife received only backed up this
idea further I tried getting ahold of
Emily and Elena to see who they got
gifts for but neither one of them could
be reached the next and final couple was
Marco and Gina they had taken an uber
home from the party so all I had to do
was show up and ask to see their ride
history
I arrived Marco was actually kind of
upset that I was accusing them I thought
to myself this was it it must be one of
them but I hadn't really planned for
what I would do if I'd gotten this far I
didn't bring anything to defend myself
with not only was Marco a big guy but it
was two against one i clenched my fist
behind my back and slowly stepped away
as Marco yelled at me going on about how
he was appalled that I didn't trust him
after everything we've been through I
figured that my best bet was to turn and
run for my car then I could hopefully
make it get away and alert the police
tension within me builds as I waited for
him to make him move just when I was
ready to turn and run Gina came up with
the phone to her ear and said that Terry
was on line and she had just found out
about the car crash she invited me and
to show me the evidence I was looking
for and stupidly I accepted for all I
knew this could have been an act to lure
me in and make me more vulnerable still
when Gina delivered the news I thought I
saw something change in Marcos
expression like an understanding had
come over him like he realized now why I
had to see their whereabouts last night
still I was jumpy inside with her house
and in my mind I was keeping track of
where they both were at all times for my
own safety though I tried not to show it
Marco brought up there trip history on
uber and to my surprise they had gone
home after the party no doubt about it
they also showed me who their Secret
Santa recipients were Marcos was Cynthia
and Gina's was James I told them I had
to be on my way and had
where a van was pulling up to the curb
by their house as soon as I looked up at
it it haphazardly sped away down the
street I ran after it and found that the
license plate was covered with black
tape it was just like what Terry had
described to me I dialed 911 and 11 Oh
what just happened he was still going
after people so I knew I was racing the
clock here there were only two suspects
led Troy and Cynthia the two singles who
had been flirting at the party I hope to
god it wasn't Troy after I'd put so much
into my gift for him but deep down I
knew it was the nature of the crime at
my house pointed to it being a male
still I touched base with my wife and
told her to look into Cynthia while I
confronted him everything was boiling
down to this
Troy lived alone so I wouldn't be able
to get any info from anyone else he did
live in an apartment complex however so
there had to be a camera somewhere that
would prove he was out several hours
after the party ended I gave the police
chief a call and he agreed to send
someone out to meet me at Troy's
apartment complex with a warrant I
waited out by the office this was our
chance to nail him what was taking them
so long as I waited around I heard a
familiar voice
it was Troy I was so stupid of course
he'd come back after nearly getting
caught back at Marcos this was not good
he knew I knew but he didn't let on to
it right away well so you can play at
that game
my only choice was to play dumb he
pretended to be surprised to see me he
always did have a good poker face I told
him that I had come to check on him when
I heard about James and Terry he told me
he had just heard this morning and went
over to the hospital to visit James he
was finally telling me something I could
believe a good move on his part it would
definitely make them less suspicious of
him but that wouldn't work on me I'd
caught him red-handed
but he knew I knew too much what was his
plan how long was he gonna play dumb all
I had to do was stall a little bit
longer I decided to press him on it I
asked him if anything weird had happened
after he had left the night before I was
hoping to trip him up with an
inconsistency in his story something
that didn't line
with the actual timeline of events all I
got out of him though was that he had
gone straight home
he asked what I had done after everyone
had left and it was at that moment that
something clicked in my head he was
going to try to paint me as the villain
he knew we would be home in to sleep
after the party so we would have no
alibi to prove that we hadn't gone and
run down James's car before coming back
to set our own Christmas tree ablaze in
an attempt to make ourselves look like
the victims after all we'd set up the
party
we could have structured it so that my
wife would receive the creepy note from
me he was going to try to pin it all on
me but I was one step ahead of him
the detective arrived I told Troy he was
busted but I knew it would be a battle
to prove my own innocence as well he
continued to play dumb
the detective provided the apartment
complex with a warrant and we all sat
down and watched the footage this next
part I deeply regret I'll never be able
to erase that look of betrayal out of my
mind because the footage proved that
Troy was innocent I wish I had more time
to apologize for accusing him but I had
to get check on my wife all signs now
pointed to Cynthia being the culprit I
rushed home where my wife informed me
she had just gotten off the phone with
Cynthia's roommate
Cynthia was also innocent this didn't
make any sense we declared everyone who
was at the party had we overlooked
someone was it somebody else outside of
the group we soon got our answer if
you're easily disturbed I suggest you
don't continue we got another call from
the police chief Emily and Elena we're
dead
somebody had broken down their door and
slit both of their throats leaving them
to bleed out under the Christmas tree
the killer had also slathered a message
on the carpet and blood it read was
about [ __ ] with arrows pointed up at
them I was sickened just by hearing
about this but the police had a strong
lead on who the killer might be mark
Berkley
Cynthia Zacks from last year Secret
Santa the a-hole who got her a nice tray
for a gift apparently one of the first
things the detective on our case did was
contact the developer of the Secret
Santa app he was given a master list of
everyone involved I guess we never
removed mark from the list when we added
Troy this year and the app told Troy to
get a present for mark Troy must have
thought it was supposed to be Marco
seeing as how he would have no idea who
mark even is that would also explain why
Marco ended up with two gifts then mark
must have snuck in at some point and
dropped my wife's gift into the pile it
was all starting to come together we
also found out that Mark had completely
lost his mind when Cynthia had broken up
with him a little over a year ago there
were multiple police reports of him
threatening her stalking her and
loitering outside her apartment
maybe when Mark accidentally got the
email about our Secret Santa that
somehow set him off again and he decided
to terrorize all of us everyone's still
in her life
everyone who's as close to her as he
wishes he could be the chief told me
that he had already sent his squad over
to Cynthia's as mark would likely be
heading over there next after having hit
every other couple at the party but I
knew that wouldn't be the case if Mark
really had snuck into the party to
deliver the fake gift he'd have seen
what went on between Cynthia and Troy
and he'd be in a furious rage he was
saving his best most brutal cold-blooded
strike for last in Cynthia was never on
his hit list I raced over to Troy's as
quickly as I could but feared I may be
too late when I arrived to find his
front door had been left wide open I
walked inside
it seemed strangely empty my heart sank
was I too late or was try even home when
Mark had arrived I called out Troy no
response mark I headed into the kitchen
where I saw that the dish rack and
silverware organizer I'd gotten him had
been put to good use
he'd finally tidied up his crazy mess of
stuff for that little moment I was glad
I was able to get him something
worthwhile but then it happened I never
heard it coming but I did see a shadow
come over me
as I noticed the other gift I had gotten
Troy the knife block but one of the
knives was missing
number 18 blind dates
I'd always found the concept of a blind
date to be somewhat of a gamble at best
it could lead to a very fun time and who
knows maybe even something more but you
run the risk of a terrible and awkward
hour or more and you never really know
what you might get Tara and I exchanged
names and phone numbers online then
decided only to text each other before
the date in order to preserve the blind
aspect of the encounter I arrived at the
restaurant a few minutes early to find
that she was already there we quickly
got a table and sat down after our
initial introductions one of the first
things that she did was suggest that we
both turn off our phones for the
remainder of the date while I was
surprised at her progressive request I
quickly agreed and powered down my
device I had been on all too many bad
dates where the girl had fallen back and
looking at her phone at the first hint
of an awkward moment I mean I've been
guilty of it too so I figured we may as
well at least attempt to get to know
each other now that we had taken the
time to arrange a date we started with
the small talk the city our jobs the
obligatory stuff then she started to ask
some weird questions questions like have
you ever thought about murdering someone
I told her we all have at some point
right in a joking manner of course she
went on about how planning the perfect
murder in her head was kind of a fun
hobby of hers when she asked me how I
would do it I explained that I kind of
liked the Alfred Hitchcock idea of
stabbing someone with an icicle
I wasn't really sure what to think when
I heard what she said next she told me
if you do it right you've got no reason
to make the evidence disappear of course
I was curious as to where she was going
with this these detectives always look
for a motive
she explained so you simply have to have
no reason to be there no connection to
the person and of course no witnesses
[Music]
well it would be easy to get away with
something like that I did have to wonder
why would you want to kill a random
person she just said that she finds it
kind of exciting it's not that I didn't
realize this conversation was weird
normally I wouldn't find myself talking
about such things with a girl
nonetheless on the first date but for
whatever reason I didn't really mind
discussing it with her I even found it
kind of fun at the end of the date I
picked up the bell and she asked if I
had any plans for the rest of the night
taking the hint I invited her back to my
place and before long we were off upon
arriving home I stepped into the
bathroom to freshen up and brush my
teeth just in case while I was in there
I turned my phone back on to see if I
had missed any messages while I was out
on the date Tara was waiting for me out
in the living room so I tried to be
quick I noticed just one message on my
phone it was from Tara thirty minutes
ago
that's odd we hadn't even left the
restaurant thirty minutes ago both of
our phones were off at the time I opened
the message Hey
I'm so sorry I didn't make it someone
slashed my tires I tried calling but
your phone was dead did you still want
to meet up as I tried to comprehend what
I just read
I heard her doing something out in the
kitchen the sound of a drawer opening or
something I was about to go out there
and find out what she was doing
rummaging through my stuff when a wave
of realization hit me with a petrifying
force no reason to be there no
connection to the person no witnesses I
locked the bathroom door grabbed my
phone and called the number I had for
Tara it rang once twice three times I
started sweating bullets as I saw her
shadow appear
she had made an effort to make sure all
of her movements were silent then she
just stood outside the door after what
seemed like ages I heard a voice on the
other side of the line hello hello the
woman that picked up the phone was not
the same woman standing outside my
bathroom door not knowing what else to
do I hung up the phone and began to dial
9 wha she must have heard me dialing
because she then grabbed the door handle
and tried to come into the bathroom as
soon as she realized that it was locked
she quickly moved away from the door I
braced myself for her to barge down the
door or something
that's when I heard my front door open
and quickly closed I assumed that she
had left but I didn't dare leave the
safety of the locked bathroom until the
cops had arrived and locked down the
area of course they found no trace of
the woman I tried to get them to take
down a description of her appearance but
I was told that there was no case since
I had invited her in she hadn't actually
broken any law as far as I could tell
nothing had been stolen besides without
knowing her name or who she actually was
it was unlikely that they would have
found her anyway eventually I got into
contact with the real Tara and told her
about what happened she was
understanding when I said that I no
longer felt comfortable meeting up for a
blind date it's been a couple of days
now since the incident and I've had an
uneasy feeling since then I've barely
gotten any sleep sometimes I think I
hear the sound of my door handle
wiggling like someone who's trying to
get in but when I get up and check on it
the sound dissipates she knew where I
lived now what was to stop her from
coming back and finishing the job I
tried to tell myself that the whole
thing was a cruel prank that she was
trying to mess with me for her own
entertainment and that she probably just
wanted to scare me or something
until today see since that day I haven't
really had much of an appetite I finally
had the stomach to eat something again
and decided to go to the kitchen and
prepare something for myself when I
found the kitchen knife put away in the
wrong drawer
number 19 creeps mik pasta narrated my
nightmare I recently began listening the
creepypasta narrations each night before
bed now I know for some people that is
probably a terrible idea
that would likely result in a state of
fear not being able to sleep or being
riddled with terrible nightmares I even
have friends that won't watch a horror
movie past 9:00 p.m. for fear that they
will not be able to sleep that night if
they do I however am NOT like most
people I've been mostly desensitized to
such movies so finding a story that
really scares me is an exciting
occurrence I welcome any nightmares that
may arise as you get older it becomes
very difficult to find anything that
scares you like when you were a child
sure there are worries and stresses that
come with adulthood but real terror
becomes a real rarity by the time you
hit eighth grade other than in your
dreams
so I started pulling up a creepypasta on
YouTube each night before bed and
letting it play as I closed my eyes
visualize the story in my head and hope
that if I was lucky maybe I'd get the
thrill of a nightmare
ransacking my thoughts that evening at
least that's what I thought I wanted and
until recently when I had a nightmare so
terrifying I've had to rethink my
outlook entirely see the strange thing
about horror narrations on YouTube is
that while all their voices can be
creepy and unsettling they also have to
be aesthetically pleasing to listeners
ears so they also tend to have the most
soothing full sounding voices out of
anyone you might hear and what I've come
to find is that often times the result
is like that of a lullaby and after
listening to a couple of their stories
their voices can ease you right to sleep
that's another reason that I had
continued to listen to stories before
bed some of my favorite narrators were
the dark somnium lady White Rabbit
mortis media and creeps Mecosta creeps
was usually my go-to for falling asleep
as he has that relaxing tone of voice
that just puts you at ease and makes it
easy to drift off while listening to
some classic
horror stories he also uploads nearly
every day so there's usually a new video
to listen to each night which is nice
every now and then creeps will upload
something known as a compilation video
which consists of all of his narrations
from that month combined into one long
video which tends to land around four
hours or so I had fallen asleep
listening to one of these compilation
videos when I discovered what I'll call
an intriguing life hack
I found that listening to a long enough
story at just the right volume can
actually result in me hearing the
creepypasta narration in my dreams this
was obviously insanely cool for me but
it didn't stop there
what I discovered was that my dreams
would actually change based on what I
was hearing in the story have you ever
had someone touch or kicking you while
you were asleep and have something
similar happen in your dream as a result
I imagine that it's the same concept
here only instead of a physical response
my brain was responding to the audio
needless to say I had a lot of fun
experimenting with this trick forcing
myself to have dreams of classic horror
stories creating playlists for myself so
I can control which stories play when I
enter my REM sleep cycle and getting
myself genuinely horrified when the
stories took a turn for the worst
at first if there was any kind of loud
noise or music change in the narrative
it would jolt me right awake but the
more I listened the more I became
desensitized to it after a couple of
months I was able to sleep through any
music or sound effects and creeps was
the soundtrack to my nightmares I worked
my way through the essentials until I
got to teethe dot jpg
had it set up so that the story would
start after 90 minutes
so basically when my dream picked up the
story had just started teeth dot jpg if
you're not familiar with it is about
four art students who live together and
come back from one summer break to one
of the roommates undergoing a strange
and disturbing behavior change what made
this experience so real for me was that
when you're in a dream you don't really
question what's going on for whatever
reason so although the characters in
this creepypasta Josh lily and Daniel
the psycho one are completely fictional
I felt like they were my closest friends
during the dream my mind never really
tried to challenge the fact that I just
lived in this world with these
characters in one of the early scenes
Daniel goes missing at night and I as
the main character of the story end up
finding the creepy teeth dot jpg file on
his computer being anything I noticed
that he had a USB plugged in and two
files on the screen Oana was called
ventus photos and the other file was a
singular image named teeth dot jpg I
clicked on the deads in the dream when
I'm going through the files I keep on
looking over to the door and despite the
fact that I know this story in real life
it's like I don't know what's going to
happen in the moment so I feel like
Daniel is gonna come walking in any
second the strange thing was every time
I looked back at the door it was
different
the lighting outside
and the angle at which the door was open
was always different I would see shadows
on the wall sometimes despite the fact
that nobody was really there that was
tripping me out but in addition to that
there were a bunch of files in Daniels
computer other than those mentioned in
the story and I looked at them despite
the fact that creeps narration did not
instruct me to do so there were photos
real photos from my Facebook page most
of which were ones that I was in me and
my friends and my girlfriend me and my
ex-girlfriend and again at the time I
didn't realize I was dreaming I was just
taking this all at face and it was
really freaking me out I ran out of the
room and hit my foot on the floor
on the way out it really hurt it wasn't
like a dream at all the pain was so
realistic and it was pulsing through my
leg there were more strange deviations
that occurred in this dream for example
when we suspected Daniel of doing
something to Lily and went through his
bags I picked up the satchel and ended
his contents onto the coffee table I
immediately recognized the items that
poured out the bag these were all the
same objects that I have sitting on my
nightstand
the alarm clock my phone a box of tissue
and a picture frame I reached out to
pick up my alarm clock but when my hand
got to the point of touching it I
couldn't feel anything I couldn't pick
it up since this was a dream I didn't
find this that out of the ordinary I
just felt more like I was doing
something wrong as opposed to some kind
of glitch in reality there were also
some photographs of Lily
we notice in the back of the photographs
there were labels and each tooth on each
photo was marked though notes on the
photos that said things like remove or
replace I found that this was much
easier for me to interact with and I was
able to pick up each one and inspect the
markings they were polaroid photos which
doesn't really make sense they keep back
on it but each one had Lilly's teeth
notated with permanent marker we began
searching for Lilly and it felt like we
were wandering aimlessly forever days
even it's strange how time can seem to
be uncompressed when you're dreaming
eventually we found the house
Josh kicked down the door and we poured
into the basement upon entering I was
hit with a foul odor that instantly
sickened me typically the smell had
usually been a non-factor for me in my
dreams but this just like when I banged
my foot was so real I didn't want to be
there anymore I couldn't stand to go on
but I was fighting the movement of my
own body
it was obeying each of creeps commands
which was booming over us in his calm
familiar voice and echoing all
throughout the basement I wasn't in
control anymore but I could still feel
that wretched nausea caused by that
smell I wanted to go outside and throw
up but I couldn't do that I was
continuing against my own will I looked
at Josh and he actually seemed to be
unaffected by it and it was at this
point where I think I gradually started
to realize that I was in a dream no
a nightmare that I could not wake up
from
we found Lily's sweater at this point I
did actually throw up I'll avoid the
grotesque details of what happened next
as much as possible but I have to get my
point across through my own eyes I could
see the puke piling up on the floor but
how I felt was much different than that
it was like it was piling up and
wouldn't leave my mouth I started
spitting choking doing whatever I could
to prevent myself from drowning in my
own waste
but the gross nests of all of this was
making me sicker and making it clog my
mouth even more I felt like I was going
to suffocate and then somehow I was able
to clear my Airways I'm not really sure
how anyways sorry about that
no more gross parts we wandered around
in the dark someone turned on a red
light I heard Josh scream it was
probably the loudest thing I had ever
heard it was so loud that it
rarely overtook the sound of creeps Nick
pastas narrations it echoed everywhere
in the room piercing my eardrums it felt
like my head might pop but then the
echoes slowly faded out that's when I
saw Lily eyes gouged teeth repurposed at
this point I knew I was in a nightmare
and I wanted out
I tried sitting up opening my eyes none
of that worked I heard the footsteps
come up behind me I pinched myself
nothing this way that's okay it's all
for the sake of ARBs Daniels dialog was
perfectly in sync with the booming
narration I beat my fists against my
body no luck I started punching myself
in the face no matter what I did I
couldn't wake myself up that's when I
was ganked backwards into the dark my
stomach dropped as this happened and my
eyes were blurry filled with tears I
kicked I thought but I couldn't make
contact daniel was beating and
bludgeoning me with what must have been
a somewhat sharp metal post all the pain
was real it was an intense searing pain
it was unlike anything I had felt in
waking or in sleep I was bleeding I
could tell because I reached to grasp my
injury and it felt a wet and then
suddenly it just stopped as creeps gave
the final narration I could hear Lily
choking I thought I was done for but
then everything around me the entire
environment just faded away I found
myself laying in a white void I guess
it's true what they say how you can't
die in your dream
I've been laying here for what feels
like days but realistically has been
about nine hours and 15 minutes how do I
know this my alarm just went off for the
second time and it isn't waking me up
I'm starting to doubt it ever well
[Music]
number twenty Tower of Terror last ride
when I heard that the Tower of Terror at
Disney's California Adventure was being
remodeled into a guardians of the galaxy
ride I immediately made plans with my
friends Joey and Matt to go pay the ride
one last visit we all decided to take a
Monday off and visit the park on the
last day of the rides operation in hopes
that there might be some kind of special
send-off if you've never been to Disney
Tower of Terror was a part dark ride
part freefall ride themed around an
abandoned Hollywood hotel guests are
told that they're entering a special
episode of The Twilight Zone
five people riding on an elevator on one
Halloween night in the 30s were struck
by lightning causing them and an entire
section of the hotel to disappear into
another dimension let me make one thing
clear I was never the type of guy who
believes in ghosts that's part of what
made me love the Tower of Terror though
the theming and effects were so well
done that you really did feel like you
were stepping into a dimension where
ghosts do exist and it was a lot of fun
as we walked through the Hollywood
Boulevard area of the park towards
Hollywood Tower I was disappointed to
see that they had already stripped off
the walls leaving behind a tower of
scaffolding where construction workers
were already at work transforming the
outside appearance of the ride as we
turn the corner to the street where the
tower was located we were met with a
huge line pouring way outside the
ordinary queue area understandably it
seems like lots of other Disney fans had
the same idea that we did and wanted to
give the ride a proper send-off we
decided to hit up some of the other
rides first and return to the Tower of
Terror once the Sun had gone down this
turned out to be a great idea or so it
seemed at the time because most of the
rest of the park was relatively empty in
comparison we ended up getting on just
about everything else that we wanted to
before returning to the Tower of Terror
that evening the tower was lit with this
ominous glowing blue lights as we
approached it for the final time there
was still a very long line when we got
there which we expected so it was
getting pretty late by the time we even
hit the front gates of the attractions
official queue Joey was starting to get
nervous about us even making it in
before the park closed even though they
were open late that night we were
actually one of the last groups to go
through before they started turning
people away after welcoming us to the
Hollywood Tower Hotel a man in a bellhop
uniform with dark circles under his eyes
closed up the giant metal gates behind
us presumably are never to be opened
again
at first I was feeling relieved to have
made it in time to go on the ride but I
was quickly overcome with an uneasy
feeling something was off before
entering the building the line winds
through the main level terrorists
leading up to the building's entrance I
know the area is supposed to look worn
down by the elements but it looked even
shabby er than usual the plants were all
overgrown and some of the lampposts were
broken making it very difficult to see I
even came close to stepping on some
broken glass on the ground but the
strangest part was the screaming these
were no ordinary theme park screams
though they sounded like screams of
agony like someone was being tortured we
were wondering what was getting such
violent reactions out of the riders but
eventually came to find that the
screaming was coming from the speakers
hidden around the area I'm not sure if
that made me feel any better to be
honest why would they be playing such
disturbing audio for their guests it all
just seems so weird when we got to the
covered area just outside the building
it seemed like the pillar is holding up
the structure had some considerable
decay and all the windows were broken I
couldn't remember exactly what this area
looked like last time I was here but I
was fairly certain it was at least a
little bit more put together than this
after what seemed like forever we
finally made it into the hotel this is
when things really got weird
normally the hotel lobby is made to look
like it was abandoned in the 30s which
still was only this time the room was
filled with 15 to 20 Disney employees
all wearing the same Hollywood Tower
Hotel bellhop uniform they were standing
straight up like soldiers all around the
major set pieces in the room and every
single one of them was just staring at
us it was almost as if they were
guarding something but none of them said
one word the entire time Matt even tried
asking one of the employees how much
longer would be until we reached the
front of the line to which the guy made
eye contact with him and just stared
into his soul with a completely straight
face I'll never forget the look of those
blue eyes with the dark bags underneath
piercing at us from his pale almost
grayish skin at this point I was
thinking that this all must be part of
the parks special going-away present to
the fans of the ride and they were
really going all out to make the last
night as creepy as possible I let myself
think that they were really outdoing
themselves and I was enjoying the show I
also noticed that the iconic owl statue
in the center of the lobby was
and it was replaced with the sign that
said the Silver Lake sisters live at the
tip-top Club only tip-top Club was
crossed out in red ink and replaced with
the word Lobby at some point some
construction workers came in and tried
to remove the sign and some of the other
furniture this was the first time I saw
one of the bellhops to react and speak
up he grabbed the construction workers
hand and said sir
please the hour is not yet upon us I
assumed that this was also part of the
show I mean they wouldn't really be
clearing the place out minutes after
closure right at this point
riders are taking in groups to the hotel
library for a briefing video Matt and
Joey walked ahead into the library but
when I tried to pass through the bellhop
stopped me and told me to wait for the
next group I tried to explain that I was
with those two guys but the bellhop
wouldn't let me pass Matt and Joey
didn't seem to notice I was gone but I
figured I would catch up with them
before they boarded the elevator when it
was my turn to go see the briefing video
there were only a couple people left in
line behind me so the three of us went
in we get into the orientation room and
the lights go out we sit there in the
dark for what seems like ages that's
when I hear someone shuffle around
behind me I could swear it was just me
and those two other guests who had come
into the library I was positive that
they were the only ones behind me in
line I had to think that whoever was
behind me was just one of the employees
but then seemingly just to disprove that
theory the guy who moves closer to me
and starts breathing down my neck I was
getting very uncomfortable but then just
as I was about to say something the
orientation video starts so I just take
a step forward away from that creepy
Hyneman
you unlock this door with the key of
imagination behind it is another
dimension dimension of sight a dimension
of sight a dimension of mind I wasn't
sure if there was something weird going
on with rod serling the voice almost
like it was a pitch or something you're
moving into a land of both shadow and
substance of things and ideas just
crossed over me - that's what exam the
rest of the introduction video went on
as it normally does that is until it got
to the part where rod addresses the
audience it's not a story of the
twilight zone will be your last okay now
that was definitely not normal they must
have changed up the intro video for the
final night or something this is humane
recognizes and million serfs elevator
still in operation but not as well at
midnight tonight normal operation of
this machine was seized and at that
moment the stars will come out to play
when this happens you will have to fend
for yourself and your safety is not
guaranteed you are about to embark on a
ride through history in your destination
it's what it said all right this is
exactly why we wanted to come on the
last day I was so excited I couldn't
wait to find Joey and Matt and get on
this ride the doors opened and we
continued onto the void the last part of
the hotel before we get into the
elevator the creep who was standing
behind me didn't join us however I
looked back and saw him just standing
there in the dark I couldn't see him
that well he was basically just a
silhouette in this lighting but I think
I made out the outline of a bellhop
uniform whatever I scanned the boiler
room for my friends but I didn't see
them anywhere I hoped that they hadn't
gotten on the ride without me the more I
searched around for them the more I
realized that the entire room felt kind
of
at least considering how many people had
just been in front of us
it was also freezing down here I was
getting goose bumps and know it was
January but we were inside it was
Southern California after all it doesn't
usually get this cold the other two guys
from the library and I were directed
past the usual Boarding stations up to a
creaky stairway and leading up this was
completely new to me I mean I remembered
seeing these stairs before but I always
thought they were just a decoration to
make the hotel feel more fleshed out
than it really is or maybe one of those
secret entrances for the cast members to
access their changing race and whatnot
apparently I was wrong and there are
more elevated entrances up above as well
as more pipes and machinery and theming
the only thing that wasn't up there was
people I tried to text my friends to see
where they were at but my phone was dead
from a long day at the park one of the
employees led us to a station that was
completely empty we didn't have to wait
long for the car to arrive the elevator
shaft doors parted and we entered the
ride I chose the seat towards in the
middle and the other two guys filled in
on either side of me the Tower of Terror
starts by travelling up to the first
floor where the doors open and the
guests see a mirror the narrator then
asked them to wave besides the real
world when the doors opened for a ride I
saw a man sitting directly behind me
with what appeared to be a hunting rifle
this really startled me thinking it
might have been some kind of effect like
the hitchhiking ghosts in the haunted
mansion I turned back to see that there
really was someone sitting there there
was the creepy bellhop guy again
at this point I started to freak out not
only was this the second time that this
guy in excellent
appeared behind me but he was carrying a
weapon I know Disney can have a dark
side at times but this is still Disney
we're talking about a family company I
was getting really scared that something
was very wrong here but what could I do
I was strapped into the seat so I start
to scream and panic I don't remember
exactly what I said but I do remember
the ride violently jolting down a floor
next scene is a hallway full of guest
rooms where riders are shown the ghosts
of the 500 fellows who disappeared years
ago only this time the Holograms looked
shockingly realistic and they don't seem
to notice us they're just standing in
the hotel talking the audio isn't that
loud but they seem to be arguing with
the employee about something and the
woman is sobbing again it was difficult
to hear over the rain and thunder but
she said something along the lines of
don't make us go she's crying begging
and pleading and the employee is just
standing there with a disgusted look on
his face before I can gather any more
information a huge flash of lightning
fills the room this may have been a
special effect but I distinctly remember
feeling the heat of this lightning
strike what I saw when the smoke cleared
completely devastated me I saw all five
of the bodies sprawled out on the floor
in a disturbingly realistic death scene
the man seemed to have vomited all over
himself and the little girl's hair was
standing up on end but the creepiest
part had to have been her hide which had
rolled into the back of her head her
eyelids seemed to be sparked open and it
was almost as if her blank stare was
pointed right at me I was completely at
a loss for words sounds anything when
the ride jerked upward again to the top
level the ride stopped at the top like
it always does it was dark there were
only a few main lights left on in the
park I guess the other major attractions
were already shut down
instead of the usual audio the narrator
was just laughing like a madman after a
while it went quiet and nothing happened
I was beginning to think that the ride
was stuck and to be honest it was almost
a relief after everything that I had
seen the moment of salus however was
short-lived when I felt the man behind
me who I guess I had temporarily
forgotten about it in all the chaos grab
on to my shoulder at this point I knew
there was nobody who could help me but I
was internally freaking out and I didn't
dare turn around and acknowledge what he
was doing now I know that people are
gonna call me out and say that I made
the story up for attention and I know
people are gonna try to prove that most
of these occurrences are absolutely
impossible and I can't really blame them
for that but what I saw next even if it
was just for a fraction of a second has
stuck in my mind perfectly since that
night and I'm 100% sure of what I saw as
the ride started to drop and the man
behind me increased the pressure on my
shoulder the on ride photo camera
flashed for a split second I saw three
construction workers hanging by the neck
from the top pole upon which the camera
is mounted
these were not Holograms and even though
I only saw them for a split second I'm
quite sure that they were not props
either after that first drop the
elevator intended to bounce up and down
at nauseating speeds between the g-force
and the pressure of the men grabbing my
shoulder I felt like I was about to pass
out I actually started to black out and
close my eyes when I felt the ride come
to a screeching halt I was ready for
this horrific nightmare to be over but
apparently the ride had other plans once
I opened my eyes and regained my
composure I found myself on the second
floor the one with all the guest rooms
the dead bodies were still there but now
they had ghosts standing over them
motioning for us to come closer this was
actually probably the most normal thing
I had seen since getting on the ride as
it resembled the scene that usually
takes place on this floor during normal
operation then to my surprise our
harnesses came off I was essentially
frozen in complete shock what the hell
was going on the creep up behind me
continued to hold my shoulder while the
other two riders got out of their seats
and casually walked through the door to
the right which to this point I wasn't
even aware was a real door I'd always
just thought it was a facade much like
the stairs in the boiler room earlier
after I'm not exactly sure how long I
snapped out of my days and realized this
was my chance to get out I've wriggled
myself free of the man's grasp and made
a beeline for the right-side door it was
a lot I banged myself against it he
didn't budge so I darted across to the
left side door glancing at the elevator
car in passing the man in the bellhop
uniform was just sitting there giving me
this creepy sadistic grin to my surprise
the door and the left work and I slammed
it shut behind me I stumbled up a seedy
narrow staircase at the end of which was
another door I burst it through hoping
to make it to the lobby or something but
instead found myself in an abandoned
swimming pool what in the world I mean
how could this possibly exist here I
know for a fact that the pool has never
been part of the ride the queue or any
of the theming surrounding it I vaguely
remember a sign pointing to a pool on
the beginning of the line but come on it
was just a sign did I stumble upon one
of those crazy Disney secrets like Walt
Disney's New Orleans square apartment or
the fabled basketball court under the
peak of the Matterhorn
perhaps this pool was at one time an
employee lounge of some kind
all the tiles were cracked and the pool
is filled with rust and who knows what
else there were a couple of dark objects
at the bottom of the pool I had to force
myself not to look and assumed that
there were pool chairs or something but
I had a bad feeling in my gut about what
they may actually be whatever it was it
looked disgusting and I wanted to get
the hell out of there I looked around
for another exit but the first thing I
noticed was a lump across the pool my
first thought was that it was a dead
body until I saw a guy stand up and
start wobbling around like a drunk he
was wearing a hoodie and tattered jeans
my initial impression was that this was
a homeless guy who had somehow snuck in
and was living here when he saw me he
started to screaming at me he kept
saying you can't take my home and
cursing at me he was clearly intoxicated
as soon as I figured out where the door
was I made a mad dash for the exit which
may have in fact been an entrance
because it led me to a dimly lit locker
room I guess that if that was one time
pool for employees that this must be the
corresponding locker room the lockers
were pretty small and most of them were
open and empty the only sound I could
hear was that of running water on the
far side of the locker room in the dark
after all that I'd experienced I thought
it might be best to approach the door on
the other side of the room more
stealthily I was also feeling very sick
and needed to catch my breath I still
felt like I was going to pass out I walk
over to the source of the water keeping
my footsteps as quiet as possible
there are a few shower stalls up ahead I
poked my head into the first and it's
empty I proceeded continuing to check on
the second third and fourth stalls but
what I see in the fourth stall stops me
dead in my tracks in the corner of the
shower an old man stands in the showers
stream he's naked senile and borderline
deformed and he has his head buried in
the corner luckily he doesn't seem to
notice me
so I decide to tiptoe past him they get
to the door I make it across safely but
as I grip the door handle I hear a
terrifying cry out from behind me I see
you you'll never get me out of here
you're the one who has to go
I hear wet footsteps charging out of the
shower stall behind me it wastes no time
yanking the door open and thumbing my
way through the next room in the dark
this leads me back to the original
mirror room the elevator car from the
ride is now there seemingly just waiting
for me the creepy bellhop guys in the
same seat can send him to stare me down
I don't even bother to stop running
across the mirror room through the door
on the other side now I'm in another
hotel corridor but different from the
one upstairs at the end of the hall I
see a woman and yet another bellhop
character this one wearing a red pair of
Mickey Mouse ears with an Iron Man logo
on it the two are having a dispute she's
screaming and grabbing onto the sides of
the doorframe as he violently tries to
pull her out of the room she's screaming
please don't make me go and he would
just methodically respond by telling her
that her stay is up and she's welcome to
check into one of their other hotels he
then yanked her hard enough for her to
lose grip on the door and she flew
across the hallway crashing her head on
the wall hard enough to draw blood she
collapsed on the floor in front of him
that's when he looked up and noticed me
with the same intense stare that the
bellhops down lobby had given us my
vision was starting to get blurry so I
decided to go into one of the rooms to
see if I could buy myself some time I
assumed that all the doors were fakes
but was pleasantly surprised when one of
them actually opened leading to yet
another corridor I was too tired to try
to comprehend how this was possible
given the layout of the ride and given
the fact that these
rooms have no reason to exist in the
first place just then the room went dark
and the walls floor and ceiling became
projection map with the starry night sky
the same effect used in the second floor
of the actual version of the riot at the
end was a single door I took this as the
metaphorical exit to the twilight zone
so I ran to it as fast as I could as I
was running I heard the narrator's
booming voice one last time next time
you try to mess with history
make sure you know just what kind of
thick and sea you're filling or you may
find a few nasty surprises coming your
way you may or may not have made it
through tonight but to close this door
is to forever live on in your head in
that's why like zone and just like that
it was over the sound of the xxx
soundtrack played into my ears and I was
making my way down the stairs trying to
think about if Joey and Matt had a
similar experience to what I had and
what happened to those two strangers
what if I was the only one to make it
out who would believe me a light caught
my eye the ride photo at the top of the
drop the guy was grabbing on my shoulder
not to mention the hanging bodies that
would also probably be in frame I ran up
to the preview screen if I needed proof
this would be it but when I looked at
the photo it was just me and two other
guys no creepy bellhop no bodies just a
regular ride photo the gift shop was
completely devoid of any gifts or people
so feeling defeated I passed through and
met up with my friends as I had feared
they made no mention of anything
abnormal and asked if I was okay a
regular Disney employee in a yellow
button-down shirt informed us that the
park is closing and to make our way to
the exits we walk out of the park I
turned back to see the lights coming
down in the Tower of Terror one last
time there are already cranes in place
ready to start ripping pieces off the
structure other than that though it
looks completely normal from the outside
no hanging bodies at the top nothing out
of the ordinary before turning back I
see a window open on one of the floors
new to the top I stopped walking Joey
asked what's gotten into me as I stare
back at the ride for the final time
a light shines out the window and the
silhouette of a bellhop sticks his head
out and waves at me I don't plan on
going back to ride the new guardians of
the galaxy ride when it opens I believe
in ghosts
thanks for listening to all of all daint
a creepypasta your total today comes out
to 249 thousand one hundred seventy two
dollars and eighty four cents but if you
like this video right now I'll waive
that fee and give you everything you
just listened to absolutely free if you
made it this far my question for you is
this if I were to make a movie out of
one of these stories which one would you
like to see adapted the most let me know
when you stop by the comment section and
congratulations on making it to the end
of season one this season I tried to
push the boundaries of what could be
done with an audio horror story I
brought you all new and original scripts
some of the best narrators in the game
cinematic sound design and a completely
original score next season I'm taking it
even further and doing some things that
have never been done before I've already
got a ton of cool episodes planned for
season two and I'm hoping to once again
change the game of audio based horror
and continue to collaborate with some of
your favorite memories if that's
something you'd like to see then make
sure you're subscribed to seize these
worlds for new Horrors every week ring
that bell for notifications and I'll see
you in the next season
assuming we both survive
[Music]
you